Hey guys, my name is Sean Hayes, I know we haven't repeated our names in a while, but my name is Sean Hayes. Yeah, this is Jason Baby, just to be clear, I gotta get dressed, we're about to start, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. In case you don't know what the show's like, one of us brings down a kiss, the other doesn't know about it. It's a surprise.
嘿大家，我是肖恩·海耶斯，我知道我们有一阵子没重复我们的名字了，但我叫肖恩·海耶斯。没错，我是杰森·贝比，为了说清楚，我得去穿衣服，我们马上要开始了，对吧？对对对。如果你不知道这个节目是什么样的，我们其中一个人会带来一个惊喜，另一个人事先不知道。这是一个惊喜。
I don't know what we got. And I'm Will Arnett. Is it my turn yet? Sorry. And welcome to SmartLess. Do you want to see a great photo I got? Do you like photos? Oh yeah, that was today's golf outfit.
我不知道我们有什么。我是威尔·阿奈特。轮到我了吗？抱歉。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。你想看我拍的一张很棒的照片吗？你喜欢照片吗？哦，对了，那是今天的打高尔夫球的装束。
Yeah, I went with the light pants today because it's warm out here in Los Angeles. Look at Jason, Jason's wife Amanda sent this dancing in the morning. Is that you, Jason? Well, I was happy about my outfit, just looked great, you know, I was happy. Those particular pants you've worn them before, and I gotta say they're not my favorite. Oh, they're not. Is there a compliment on the end of it, because they're white? You look great, which is, first of all, you don't look bad in them, I said they're not
是的，我今天穿了浅色的裤子，因为洛杉矶这里很暖和。看看杰森，杰森的妻子阿曼达早上发了这个跳舞的视频。那是你吗，杰森？嗯，我对我的装束很满意，看起来很棒，你知道，我很高兴。那条裤子你以前穿过，我得说那不是我最喜欢的。哦，不是吗？最后有夸奖吗，是因为它们是白色的吗？你看起来很棒，首先，你穿它们看起来并不糟糕，我说的是它们不是
my favorite. Right. No, I know. That front piece. It kind of looks like a... That's a penis. That's what we call it, the front is. The front piece.
我最喜欢的。对。不，我知道。那个前片。它看起来有点像……那是阴茎。我们就是这么叫它的，前面那个。前片。
You mean the... It's kind of like a fold over, it almost looks like a formal slack. Right. Yeah, it is. I think it is a bit of a trouser that they made there. Yeah. Sorry. Listener, just going over latest golf wear.
你是说……它有点像折叠起来，看起来几乎像一条正式的休闲裤。对。是的，确实是。我觉得那确实有点像他们做的那种裤子。是的。抱歉。听众朋友们，只是在讨论最新的高尔夫球装。
Hang on. I'm trying to put this into... Golf fashion. Sean, just so that Sean can feel... I came on a little late today. You did come on late. What's going on? You're still in the city.
等等。我正试图把它放进……高尔夫时尚里。肖恩，只是为了让肖恩感觉……我今天来得有点晚。你确实来晚了。怎么了？你还在城里吗？
I'm still in the city. I had to change... Don't you have to change clothes like two, three times a day because the humidity is just... You can walk outside. I'm just drenched in sweat. Yeah. What are you doing outside?
我还在城里。我得换……难道你不觉得一天得换两三次衣服吗，因为湿度太……你一走到外面。我就浑身湿透了。是的。你在外面干什么？
Just stay inside. You have a beautiful apartment. He's walking around, man. Yeah. No, I tried to because it's air conditioning in here. Is it real humid back east right now? Yes. It's unbelievable.
待在里面就行了。你有一间漂亮的公寓。他在到处走，伙计。是的。不，我试过了，因为这里有空调。东部现在真的很潮湿吗？是的。简直难以置信。
It's unbelievably humid right now. Yeah. It's humid out here, so it must be terrible out there because it travels. So then Sean, so you and Scotty, you just pop out of the apartment and you just start walking around. Do you have some favorite places you'd like to go to? Well, we do. I mean, there's one restaurant.
现在潮湿得难以置信。是的。这里很潮湿，所以那边肯定很糟糕，因为它会移动。那么肖恩，你和斯科蒂，你们就从公寓里出来，然后就开始到处走。你们有什么喜欢去的地方吗？嗯，我们有。我是说，有一家餐厅。
Do you bring misters? Do you guys bring misters? No, we bring misters. Just to clear. No, there's one French restaurant we like on the east side. Oh, this is what I did for the first time in my entire life. I walked through Central Park. What?
你们带喷雾器吗？你们带喷雾器吗？不，我们带喷雾器。只是为了说清楚。不，东区有一家我们喜欢的法国餐厅。哦，这是我这辈子第一次做的事。我穿过了中央公园。什么？
First time ever? What are you talking about first time ever? Oh, I get real. I mean, I've walked like, you know, just from, you know, like to that restaurant that I can't remember. Tavern on the Green? Yeah. I walked there once, but I never walked from like upper west side all the way through it
有史以来第一次？你在说什么有史以来第一次？哦，我认真了。我是说，我走过，你知道，只是从，你知道，比如走到那家我不记得名字的餐厅。绿茵酒馆？对。我走过一次，但我从来没有从上西区一路穿过它
all the way down. It's kind of scary because they have, in the center, they have all those paths that go in like 10,000 different directions. Oh, granddad. But then, yeah. Did you see the skating rink over there, too? I did. Yeah.
一直走到底。这有点吓人，因为在中心，他们有成千上万条通往不同方向的小路。哦，爷爷。但后来，是的。你也看到那边的溜冰场了吗？看到了。是的。
Yeah, the roller skating rink. It was a roller skating rink. No, in the summertime. Ma, you can't believe how big it is. Mom, huh? Well, they had people walking everywhere and people just seemingly going, they were busy. It was wild. Just walls and walls of buildings.
是的，轮滑场。那是轮滑场。不，在夏天。妈，你无法相信它有多大。妈，哈？嗯，他们有到处走动的人，人们看起来都在忙碌。太疯狂了。到处都是建筑的墙壁。
We used to, when I, back when I was, when I was first living in New York, 45 years ago, and I was very broke, we used to just walk through the park because we had nothing else to do. And it was free. And we'd just have a head full of rope and we'd just walk around with shades on, you know, gig-less. That's weed, listener. Weird.
我们过去，当我，当我刚住在纽约的时候，45年前，我非常穷，我们过去只是穿过公园，因为我们无事可做。而且它是免费的。我们脑子里装满了大麻，戴着墨镜到处走，你知道，没工作。那是大麻，听众朋友们。奇怪。
Head full of, I'd never heard of that before. Head full of rope. Yeah. And we'd just walk around and sit on the grass and, I don't know, maybe smoke some butts and then like, just walk over a different part. Yeah. Because it was free. We had nothing to do and we were, you know, we were broke, broke, broke.
脑子里装满了，我以前从没听说过这个。脑子里装满了大麻。是的。我们只是到处走，坐在草地上，我不知道，也许抽点烟，然后就像，走到不同的地方。是的。因为它是免费的。我们无事可做，而且我们，你知道，我们穷得叮当响。
But it was great. I love such a walk. But you know, my, do you guys go to a chiropractor because all you do is walk, right? In New York? Am I back as fucking killing me? What kind of shoes, what kind of shoes you got right now? By the way, this is an opportunity for you to get some new shoes. Yeah.
但那很棒。我喜欢这样的散步。但你知道，我的，你们去脊椎按摩师那里吗，因为你们所做的就是走路，对吧？在纽约？我的背痛死我了。你现在穿什么鞋，什么鞋？顺便说一句，这是一个让你买新鞋的机会。是的。
Are you ready? Speak smartly here. I like that. What do you want? What do you like? I forget what they're called. We all have them. They're called the on shoes.
准备好了吗？在这里聪明地说话。我喜欢那个。你想要什么？你喜欢什么？我忘了它们叫什么了。我们都有。它们叫昂跑鞋。
Those. You might need like leg braces or something. If you're blowing your back out, just walking. How would you feel about a wagon? And then Scottie pulls it. Would you sit in a wagon? I'm not above it. I'm not above it.
那些。你可能需要腿部支架之类的东西。如果你只是走路就把背弄伤了。你觉得坐马车怎么样？然后斯科蒂拉着它。你会坐在马车里吗？我并不排斥。我并不排斥。
You've seen the dogs with the blown out backs. Yeah. Right. With the little, little carts. I would walk around. What about a Segway? Yeah. What about a Segway?
你见过那些背部受伤的狗。是的。对。带着小小的，小小的推车。我会到处走。赛格威怎么样？是的。赛格威怎么样？
Once you get electric bikes and park them in your apartment. Yeah. Yeah. I think we have to do bikes. I think it'd be fun. Get by, but you're coming out here tomorrow. Yes. And hopefully.
一旦你买了电动自行车并把它们停在你的公寓里。是的。是的。我想我们必须买自行车。我觉得那会很有趣。买吧，但你明天要来这里。是的。希望如此。
Obviously you don't like, we'll come in. You don't have to do anything. We'll just go where you want. You're going for lunch at our friend. You're going for lunch at our friend's house. Yeah. And then you're going to look around. Yeah.
显然你不喜欢，我们会进来的。你什么都不用做。我们去你想去的地方。你要去我们朋友家吃午饭。你要去我们朋友家吃午饭。是的。然后你要四处看看。是的。
And then we have a dinner tomorrow night. Perfect. And then we leave first thing in the morning. Chappy's here. Chappy's on his way here. I can't wait. He's in, Bob is here. And my sister is here right now with my brother in law, Ed.
然后我们明天晚上有晚餐。完美。然后我们一大早就离开。查皮在这里。查皮正在来这里的路上。我等不及了。他在，鲍勃在这里。我姐姐现在和我姐夫埃德也在这里。
It's a houseful. Yeah. Yeah. Except for. It's going to be a lot of fun. Hey Jason, have fun. Yeah. You got everybody there except me, I guess.
屋子里挤满了人。是的。是的。除了。这会很有趣。嘿杰森，玩得开心。是的。我想除了我，你们都在那里。
Yeah. I know you should come out because we've got other plants. Okay. All right. We're doing other things. Okay. Yeah. You guys are going to have a different vacay, which I don't, I don't know.
是的。我知道你应该出来，因为我们有别的计划。好的。好的。我们在做别的事情。好的。是的。你们会有一个不同的假期，我不知道，我不知道。
Finish the sentence. I just don't know why you don't come out to where we are. All your friends are out here is what I'm saying. You know, it's not up to me. I'm not living in a dictatorship. This is a democratic house and there's a lot of complications to our trips. Maybe that's your problem. As you know.
把句子说完。我只是不知道你为什么不来我们这里。我想说的是，你所有的朋友都在这里。你知道，这不取决于我。我不是生活在独裁统治下。这是一个民主的家庭，我们的旅行有很多复杂的情况。也许那是你的问题。如你所知。
That's by the way, that's the thing is you think is a democracy and you do live in a dictatorship. The problem is you're not the dictator. Yeah. That's so funny. It's true. Speaking of dictator, terrible segue because it does not apply to this person at all. But I will say this is so many.
顺便说一句，这就是问题所在，你以为是民主，但你确实生活在独裁统治下。问题是你不是独裁者。是的。太搞笑了。这是真的。说到独裁者，糟糕的过渡，因为它根本不适用于这个人。但我会说这太多了。
I'm really excited. I'm excited because Sean, I can't wait to see how excited you are because this is going to hit you right in a sweet spot. Must be an athlete. Right in a sweet spot for you. And also for me, he's been in a lot of films that I just absolutely love. I remember his first film. I'm not going to say the title yet.
我真的很兴奋。我很兴奋，因为肖恩，我迫不及待地想看看你有多兴奋，因为这会直接击中你的甜蜜点。一定是运动员。直接击中你的甜蜜点。也为了我，他演过很多我绝对喜欢的电影。我记得他的第一部电影。我还不打算说出片名。
I think it was his first film, maybe a second film, but the first film that really had a lot of sort of wide acclaim with a very famous director as well. And I remember thinking like this guy, he just has, I don't know, I can't not watch him when he's on screen. He's got that thing. You know, there are certain performers who have that. That thing where you're just like you're glued to and you're with him on everything he says, no matter the role.
我想那是他的第一部电影，也许是第二部，但那是第一部真正获得广泛赞誉的电影，而且还有一位非常著名的导演。我记得当时想，这家伙，他就是有，我不知道，当他在银幕上时，我无法不看他。他有那种东西。你知道，有些表演者有那种东西。那种让你着迷，无论他演什么角色，你都会跟随他的一切的东西。
This is this guy. He's, and he's won Emmys and he's won Golden Globes and he's been a globe trotter in that he's gone around the globe on his motorcycle. He's an incredible actor. He is Obi-Wan Kenobi. He's an incredible actor. Watch! I got it right on the motorcycle.
就是这家伙。他，他赢得了艾美奖，他赢得了金球奖，他是一个环球旅行者，他骑摩托车环游世界。他是一位出色的演员。他是欧比旺·克诺比。他是一位出色的演员。看！我骑摩托车骑对了。
How's it going? Why is Ewan McGregor in Sean's wheelhouse? What are you talking about? Sean is the most massive Star Wars fan of all time. Are you joking me? Oh, right, right, right. I was thinking song and dance. What did you think?
怎么样？为什么伊万·麦克格雷格在肖恩的专长范围内？你在说什么？肖恩是有史以来最狂热的星球大战粉丝。你在开玩笑吗？哦，对，对，对。我在想唱歌跳舞。你以为是什么？
Oh, I see you. Wait, Ewan. Oh my God, this is so cool to meet you. How are you doing? I'm so nervous. I don't know why I'm so nervous. Why? Don't be nervous.
哦，我明白了。等等，伊万。天哪，见到你太酷了。你好吗？我很紧张。我不知道为什么我这么紧张。为什么？别紧张。
Sean does that to everybody. It's weird. You have nothing to be nervous about. We are absolute fools and there's nothing to this show. It's idiocy. Trust me. It's titled appropriate. You're immediately the smartest guy in the room.
肖恩对每个人都这样。这很奇怪。你没什么好紧张的。我们是彻头彻尾的傻瓜，这个节目没什么内容。这是愚蠢。相信我。标题很贴切。你立刻成了房间里最聪明的人。
Here comes Scotty. Don't worry about it. Scotty's going to lose it. Do you know who the guest is? Just let him look and don't tell him. Look at that. Oh my God. That's my husband.
斯科蒂来了。别担心。斯科蒂会疯掉的。你知道嘉宾是谁吗？让他看，别告诉他。看那个。天哪。那是我的丈夫。
Ewan McGregor, welcome and welcome. This is so cool. What an honor to have you here on the show. It's such a great pleasure for me to be on. I was just an enormous fan of yours, buddy. Do you know Train Spotting is one of my favorite movies of all time. What has he done that has been bad? Ewan, you answer that.
伊万·麦克格雷格，欢迎，欢迎。这太酷了。能在节目中邀请到你真是荣幸。能来这里真是我的荣幸。我一直是你巨大的粉丝，伙计。你知道《猜火车》是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一吗？他做过什么坏事吗？伊万，你回答那个。
Hang on. I was going to start with this. That film I'm talking about Ewan is Shallow Grave, of course. Can you talk to us a little bit of how that came together and what that experience was like and where met you in your life at that time? That film? Yeah.
等等。我本来想从这个开始。我说的那个电影，伊万，当然是《浅坟》。你能跟我们谈谈它是怎么促成的，那次经历是什么样的，以及当时它在你生命中的哪个阶段吗？那部电影？是的。
It was the first film I ever made. You were right. Is this good? Yes. Brilliant. You were right. It was the first film I ever made. I did a drama school and I did a six-month shoot
那是我拍的第一部电影。你是对的。这好吗？是的。太棒了。你是对的。那是我拍的第一部电影。我在戏剧学校，我拍了六个月
on a Dennis Potter series called Lipstick on Your Collar. So I got out of drama school and straight in front of a camera for six months, which was amazing like training, if you like, in that respect. And then I did a play and then I did a period drama called The Red and the Black. And then I went for an audition for this film called Shallow Grave. So I'd done a couple of things on television and I guess...
一部叫《衣领上的口红》的丹尼斯·波特系列剧。所以我从戏剧学校出来，直接在摄像机前待了六个月，那真是太棒了，如果可以的话，在那方面是很好的训练。然后我演了一部戏，然后我演了一部叫《红与黑》的年代剧。然后我去试镜了一部叫《浅坟》的电影。所以我已经在电视上做过几件事了，我想……
Did you know Danny Boyle before that? No. I didn't know any of them. And they were really very much like a three-person team. Danny, the director, of course, and then Andrew McDonald was the producer and John Hodge, the writer. And the three of them were very much like a creative team,
在那之前你认识丹尼·博伊尔吗？不。我不认识他们中的任何一个。他们确实非常像一个三人团队。丹尼，当然是导演，然后安德鲁·麦克唐纳是制片人，约翰·霍奇是编剧。他们三个人非常像一个创意团队，
like really truly they were. And was Trainspotting the same team? That was them, yeah. And that's when I met them the first time and I was just lucky to get... I was so hungry and so fucking like... Let me add it, you know, I felt like I'd been ready for a long time, you know?
真的，他们确实是。那《猜火车》也是同一个团队吗？那是他们，是的。那是我第一次见到他们，我只是很幸运能……我当时太渴望了，太他妈的……让我来吧，你知道，我觉得我已经准备好很久了，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then I got on the stage, you know, we shot it so quickly we built that apartment in Shallow Grave in a factory in Glasgow, you know? And it was all... It was so Brian Tafano shot it, who went on to shoot Trainspotting and Lifeless Ordinary. And he's a brilliant cinematographer.
是的，是的，是的。然后我上了舞台，你知道，我们拍得太快了，我们在格拉斯哥的一家工厂里搭建了《浅坟》里的那个公寓，你知道吗？而且这一切……布莱恩·塔法诺拍摄了它，他后来拍摄了《猜火车》和《标心者》。他是一位出色的摄影师。
I auditioned for a Lifeless Ordinary. Did you really? Oh, did you? Yeah, and for Danny Boyle, I was so nervous. I had just moved to Los Angeles and in the scene, he's supposed to throw keys at me, so I brought keys to act like they were just thrown at me. And he threw me his set of keys,
我为《标心者》试镜过。你真的试镜过吗？哦，真的吗？是的，为了丹尼·博伊尔，我太紧张了。我刚搬到洛杉矶，在那个场景里，他应该把钥匙扔给我，所以我带了钥匙来假装它们刚被扔给我。他扔给了我他的一串钥匙，
so then I had two set of keys in the scene. Did you know that he was going to do it? No, he might have heard it. No, I didn't. Wow, that's risky. He was going to do it. So, Dan, how was the shoot? Sean, how was the shoot?
所以我在那个场景里有两串钥匙。你知道他会这么做吗？不，他可能听到了。不，我不知道。哇，那太冒险了。他会这么做的。那么，丹，拍摄怎么样？肖恩，拍摄怎么样？
I didn't get it. So, I'll bet you were great in the audition, but I would imagine that those guys that you also got the job also because it seems like you kind of fit in with their kind of fabric. They just seem like good dudes like you and did that kind of bring about Trainspotting as well?
我没得到那个角色。所以，我敢打赌你在试镜中表现得很棒，但我认为那些家伙让你得到这份工作也是因为看起来你很适合他们的那种风格。他们看起来就像你一样的好人，那也促成了《猜火车》吗？
I mean, aside from your talent. Yeah, yeah, it was interesting because it was all of our first movies. Danny had been a director in the theatre for years and I think that's why he's so very good. I didn't know that. And this was his first movie and Andrew's first movie and John was a doctor who wrote this brilliant script
我是说，除了你的才华。是的，是的，这很有趣，因为那都是我们的第一部电影。丹尼多年来一直是剧院的导演，我想这就是为什么他非常出色。我不知道。这是他的第一部电影，也是安德鲁的第一部电影，约翰是一位医生，他写了这个精彩的剧本
about these people. I guess he trained in Edinburgh, so he knew about, like, Edinburgh life and living in that city. And, yeah, it was just a most amazing experience, but I felt like it was like the other things I'd done. You know, I did that period drama and I'd done that lipstick and your collar was set in the 50s
关于这些人。我想他在爱丁堡受训，所以他了解，比如，爱丁堡的生活和在那座城市的生活。而且，是的，那是最棒的经历，但我感觉它就像我做过的其他事情一样。你知道，我演过那部年代剧，我演过那部《衣领上的口红》，背景是50年代，
and it was all single-camera work anyway. So, I felt much the same until I saw it and I saw what they'd been doing, you know, visually and what Brian took the shots that Danny and Brian dreamt up. Wow. It sort of felt like... It really felt like we'd sort of made a mark on British cinema. That's how it felt when it came out.
而且无论如何都是单机位拍摄。所以，我感觉差不多，直到我看到它，我看到了他们一直在做的事情，你知道，在视觉上，以及布莱恩拍摄了丹尼和布莱恩构思的镜头。哇。它感觉就像……它真的感觉我们好像在英国电影史上留下了印记。电影出来的时候就是这种感觉。
Yes, you did. And then we took it to... It was my first adult trip to America. We came to Sundance with it. And I'd been in the States when I was nine with my parents, which was ridiculous. Nobody comes to America for holidays. Like, it's too big of a deal, you know?
是的，你们确实留下了。然后我们把它带到了……那是我第一次成年后去美国。我们带着它去了圣丹斯电影节。我九岁时和父母去过美国，那太荒谬了。没人会去美国度假。这太重要了，你知道吗？
But when I was nine, we came over. It was my first time back as a sort of grown-up. And I went to Sundance with Shallow Grave and they gave me the script there for train spotting. Oh, my God, how cool. And they always said... We're not offering you this and it's not an offer and we just want to know what you think of it.
但当我九岁时，我们来过。那是我成年后第一次回来。我带着《浅坟》去了圣丹斯，他们在那里给了我《猜火车》的剧本。哦，天哪，太酷了。他们总是说……我们不是在给你提供这个，这不是一个提议，我们只是想知道你对它的看法。
And so, I read that on the plane. I was like, fucking hell. I mean, it's the role of a lifetime, isn't it? It's like one of the great leading roles. But John... I think I'm right. John didn't think I was right for it because in the novel, in Irvine Welsh's novel, Ewan Bremner, who played Spud,
所以，我在飞机上读了它。我当时想，他妈的。我是说，这是终身难忘的角色，不是吗？这就像伟大的主角角色之一。但约翰……我想我是对的。约翰认为我不适合它，因为在小说里，在欧文·威尔士的小说里，饰演斯帕德的伊万·布莱姆纳，
had played wrents in the stage version before we made the movie. Oh, it was a play, train spotting was a play? It was a novel first and then they made a play of it and Ewan Bremner was in the play as wrent. And in fact, he's much better casting in terms of the wrenton that's written in the novel. He's much more Ewan Bremner-esque than me-esque. So, I think John wasn't quite convinced
在我们拍电影之前，在舞台版中饰演过伦顿。哦，那是一部戏，《猜火车》是一部戏？它先是一部小说，然后他们把它改编成了一部戏，伊万·布莱姆纳在戏里饰演伦顿。事实上，就小说中写的伦顿而言，他更适合这个角色。他比我更像伊万·布莱姆纳。所以，我想约翰不太确信，
and I just had to do it. So, I went away and I just lost loads of weight. I didn't eat and... Yeah. When you say you went away, where'd you go? Like a hole in the ground? Where did you go? Where do you got to go to lose weight? Well, I just did it.
但我必须去做。所以我离开了，我减了很多体重。我不吃东西，而且……是的。当你离开的时候，你去哪了？就像一个地洞？你去哪了？你去哪减肥了？嗯，我只是做了。
They still hadn't offered it to me. They still hadn't said that it was my role, but I just thought, fuck it, I'm going to make them know that it's my role. So, I went away and I just saw them now and again, but we'd made that movie together and Andrew had an office in Soho in London that I would drop into now and again.
他们还没给我提供这个角色。他们还没说那是我的角色，但我只是想，去他的，我要让他们知道那是我的角色。所以我离开了，我偶尔会见到他们，但我们一起拍过那部电影，安德鲁在伦敦苏活区有一个办公室，我会偶尔去那里。
So, I just didn't see them for a wee while. I just shed loads of weight because I was young and it was easier to do then, you know? Yeah, yeah. And I was a big... I was a nasty drinker back in the day and I remember I just started drinking white wine and clear stuff, you know, instead of...
所以我有一阵子没见到他们。我减了很多体重，因为我当时很年轻，那时候更容易做到，你知道吗？是的，是的。而且我是一个大……我过去是个讨厌的酒鬼，我记得我只是开始喝白葡萄酒和清澈的东西，你知道，而不是……
The alcoholic sort of dieting, you know? I just drink the clear ones, you know? And it seemed to work, actually, to a degree. Anyway, I lost all the weight and then I went back in to see them and I think they were like, OK, because I looked more right then. I was more sort of emaciated and stuff.
那种酗酒式的节食，你知道吗？我只是喝清澈的那些，你知道吗？而且它确实起作用了，在某种程度上。总之，我减掉了所有的体重，然后我回去见他们，我想他们当时想，好吧，因为我那时看起来更合适了。我更憔悴了之类的。
But, I mean, it was the most amazing experience making that film, too. By the way, that film had just took the world by... I was going to say, surprise, but it just took it by storm, really. I feel like that movie kind of shifted the way people made movies for a while there, the way people made movies,
但是，我是说，拍那部电影也是最棒的经历。顺便说一句，那部电影简直让世界……我本来想说，惊喜，但它确实风靡一时。我觉得那部电影在一段时间内改变了人们拍电影的方式，人们拍电影的方式，
because it was very edgy and obviously it was very raw and had a lot of... But it wasn't just for the sake of it. There was kind of a point to all of it and there was something deeper happening. It was very cool. Sean, by the way, I can see the wheel is turning. You're just hoping, like, God,
因为它非常前卫，显然非常原始，而且有很多……但不仅仅是为了前卫而前卫。这一切都有某种意义，而且发生了更深层次的事情。这非常酷。肖恩，顺便说一句，我能看到轮子在转。你只是在想，天哪，
train spotting the musical. If there's any way that Ewan could find a way to get you involved with that. Five, six, seven, eight, hero in here and then it's a more hero in there. If Danny decides to do it, you go in and this time, maybe you wouldn't bring your own keys.
《猜火车》音乐剧。如果伊万能找到办法让你参与其中。五，六，七，八，这里有海洛因，然后那里有更多的海洛因。如果丹尼决定做这件事，你进去，这一次，也许你不会带你自己的钥匙。
Keys. Wait, Ewan, speaking of that, when you guys did the drugs in the movie, it was like both incredibly... Incredible to watch this as actors, but just like, it looks so real. I can't imagine... Did Danny ever talk you through
钥匙。等等，伊万，说到这个，当你们在电影里吸毒时，这既令人难以置信……作为演员看这个令人难以置信，但看起来太真实了。我无法想象……丹尼有没有跟你谈过
what the experience was for a hard crowd? I don't even... I want to ask you if you actually did it to get into character. But like, how did you get there? Because it did look so real. By saying, I don't want to ask you, by the way, I know it's a soft ask.
对于硬核人群来说体验是什么样的？我甚至……我不想问你是否真的为了进入角色而吸毒。但是，你是怎么做到的？因为它看起来太真实了。顺便说一句，通过说我不想问你，我知道这是一个软性的询问。
Totally just an ask, isn't it? Yes, an ask. It really is. I'm not going to ask you. I'm just going to put you in a difficult position, but go ahead, Ewan. No, it's quite an interesting point because I didn't do heroin.
完全只是一个询问，不是吗？是的，一个询问。确实是。我不会问你。我只是要把你置于一个困难的境地，但继续吧，伊万。不，这是一个非常有趣的点，因为我没有吸海洛因。
I've never done heroin, but I did think about it and I thought, I don't want to do heroin's addicts to disservice by getting it wrong. Right. So I did think, I did cross my mind,
我从来没吸过海洛因，但我确实想过，我想，我不想因为弄错了而对海洛因成瘾者造成伤害。对。所以我确实想过，它确实闪过我的脑海，
and I did say to Danny... You don't want to disrespect the heroin. No, no, I was just researching. I was just trying to disrespect the addicts. What do you mean? Why do I have a lighter under this spoon? I start shooting in three weeks. Yes!
而且我确实对丹尼说……你不想不尊重海洛因。不，不，我只是在研究。我只是试图不尊重瘾君子。你是什么意思？为什么我的勺子下面有一个打火机？我三周后开始拍摄。是的！
So I brought it up and I said, look, do you think we should do it? And I got... I really thought about it because I thought, well, John, our writer, he's a doctor. Like, he could do it to us properly, you know, so that we don't die and stuff.
所以我提出来了，我说，看，你觉得我们应该吸吗？而且我……我真的考虑过，因为我想，嗯，约翰，我们的编剧，他是个医生。比如，他可以正确地给我们做，你知道，这样我们就不会死之类的。
I could probably administer the... Oh, my God. Yeah, right, so that we were safe-ish. And... But it just became apparent that that was... That was just a really disrespectful idea to the people we were working with. And we went up to Glasgow
我可能可以管理……哦，天哪。是的，对，这样我们就安全了。而且……但很明显，那是……那对我们一起工作的人来说是一个非常不尊重的想法。我们去了格拉斯哥，
and we worked with this group of recovering addicts called the Carlton Athletic Club, and they're a group of... It was predominantly guys then, and they have soccer teams, and they're all ex-junkies. But they have these football competitions, and they're five-a-side competitions,
我们和这群叫卡尔顿竞技俱乐部的康复瘾君子一起工作，他们是一群……当时主要是男的，他们有足球队，他们都是前瘾君子。但他们有这些足球比赛，他们是五人制比赛，
and they kicked our ass. Like, we... The five actors, you know? Yeah. All the young... We got our ass handed to us by all these ex-junkies. But once we started working with those guys, and we had a...
他们踢得我们落花流水。比如，我们……五个演员，你知道吗？是的。所有的年轻人……我们被这些前瘾君子打得落花流水。但一旦我们开始和那些家伙一起工作，我们有一个……
We had this guy, Eamon, who was our advisor on set, and he... He took us to some meetings, and I started listening to all these guys, and, you know, I saw guys who'd been sober a long time, clean a long time, and then some guys who just, you know,
我们有一个叫埃蒙的家伙，他是我们的现场顾问，他……他带我们去参加了一些会议，我开始听这些家伙说话，而且，你知道，我看到了那些已经清醒了很长时间，戒毒很长时间的家伙，然后是一些家伙，你知道，
who were still in withdrawal, and I felt like once I met those guys and saw what was going on in their... In their eyes, you know, I thought it would be just massively disrespectful to not have all your faculties together. So it was... It was...
那些还在戒断期的家伙，我觉得一旦我见到那些家伙并看到他们眼里发生了什么，你知道，我想如果不保持清醒的头脑，那将是非常不尊重的。所以它是……它是……
From then on, we just... Yeah, we didn't... What were you and what was the... Yeah, that's not... What was the... What was the feedback from the junkie community? Were they... Was it positive response to the film? Yeah, I...
从那时起，我们只是……是的，我们没有……你是什么，什么是……是的，那不是……什么是……瘾君子社区的反馈是什么？他们是……对电影的反应是积极的吗？是的，我……
I'm actually kind of serious. No, no, there was... Yeah, I had both... There was a backlash on the film, because people said it, you know, thought it glorified drug-taking, and I don't think so, and I've never thought so,
我其实有点认真。不，不，有……是的，电影有反弹，因为人们说，你知道，认为它美化了吸毒，我不这么认为，我也从来没这么认为，
but some people did think that, and I met a couple... I remember I was passing a guy, a homeless guy in Soho one night, and he'd seen the movie, and... He was just like... He was like, you're one of us, brother. You know, come...
但有些人确实这么认为，我遇到了一对……我记得有一天晚上我在苏活区经过一个家伙，一个无家可归的家伙，他看过那部电影，而且……他就像……他就像，你是我们的一员，兄弟。你知道，来……
You've got... He was totally on the wrong side of the fence, you know. He was like, yeah, fucking come on. Oh, dear. Wow. I guess it's better than getting stopped by the gang that loves Star Wars, right? Yeah.
你已经……他完全站在了栅栏的错误一边，你知道。他就像，是的，他妈的来吧。哦，亲爱的。哇。我想这比被喜欢《星球大战》的帮派拦住要好，对吧？是的。
What are you saying? We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. I just finished Obi-Wan, and it's so fucking good. You're so great in it. I love that. How did you get...
你在说什么？我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。我刚看完《欧比旺》，它太他妈棒了。你在里面太棒了。我喜欢那个。你是怎么得到……
How did they get James Earl Jones to come back to do the voice of Vader? I mean, that's crazy. I know. Amazing. I'm just glad they did. It's so amazing. We had such a good time doing it. It was a long time, since we shot episode three.
他们是怎么让詹姆斯·厄尔·琼斯回来为维达配音的？我是说，那太疯狂了。我知道。太棒了。我很高兴他们这么做了。太棒了。我们做这件事玩得很开心。距离我们拍摄第三部已经过去很久了。
It was 2003, and... But it felt good, you know. It felt quite good to come. I really... I was in a much better place with it, because our prequels came out, and sort of universally weren't liked by... And it was all pre-social media and everything.
那是2003年，而且……但感觉很好，你知道。回来感觉相当好。我真的……我在那方面处于一个更好的位置，因为我们的前传出来了，而且普遍不被……而且那是在社交媒体之前的一切。
So the sort of voice that we heard were the critics' voices, and they didn't like them much. And so it was pretty disappointing at the time. But the fans liked them, though. Like, that was the thing. I feel like the fans liked them. For the story.
所以我们听到的声音是评论家的声音，他们不太喜欢它们。所以当时相当令人失望。但粉丝们喜欢它们。比如，那是重点。我觉得粉丝们喜欢它们。为了故事。
And you're right. Boy, that's an interesting sort of distinction that you've made, that we do live in a time now where the critics' voices have just been completely drowned out, haven't they? Yeah, they're just aggregated now. It's just rotten tomatoes, period. Yeah.
你是对的。天哪，这是一个有趣的区分，你已经做出了，我们现在确实生活在一个评论家的声音已经被完全淹没的时代，不是吗？是的，它们现在只是被聚合了。这只是烂番茄，句号。是的。
Right. But even that doesn't really matter as much as what social media is saying. And that's not necessarily critics. It's people, right? It's other people. I think so, yeah. Do you...
对。但即使是那样，也没有社交媒体所说的那么重要。那不一定是评论家。是人们，对吧？是其他人。我想是的，是的。你……
Yeah, that's interesting. So anyway, it was hard to get back into it, or it was easy or... Well, I think when I finished the third one, I wouldn't have... If you'd asked me then, I'd be like, okay, I was always happy to be in it, and I was very...
是的，这很有趣。所以总之，回到它很难，还是很容易，或者……嗯，我想当我拍完第三部时，我不会……如果你当时问我，我会说，好吧，我一直很高兴参与其中，而且我非常……
I was always grateful to be involved in something that big and to be part of the legend of it, because I loved it. When I was a kid, I loved those films. I mean, I was seven, I think, six or seven when the first one came out. And just like, you can't...
我一直很感激能参与这么大的事情，并成为它传说的一部分，因为我喜欢它。当我还是个孩子时，我喜欢那些电影。我是说，我想第一部出来时我七岁，六或七岁。而且就像，你不能……
You know, it's in you somehow. And I know it is, because when I was working on this series, and I was faced with Vader for the first time in all his, like, scary majesty, I was totally knocked the wind out of me. It was quite scary seeing him coming at you. And Stormtroopers, like, I never...
你知道，它以某种方式在你心里。我知道它是，因为当我拍摄这个系列时，我第一次面对维达，带着他所有的，比如，可怕的威严，我完全被震撼了。看到他向你走来相当可怕。还有冲锋队，比如，我从来没有……
I never acted with Stormtroopers on the prequel, so we did scenes with Stormtroopers. And I was like a boy again, you know, just like deep inside me. And talk about a huge difference in... I mean, I know there was a gang of work between, you know, Shallow Grave and Trainspotting, and then the Star Wars work.
我从来没有在前传里和冲锋队一起演过戏，所以我们和冲锋队拍了场景。我感觉又像个男孩了，你知道，就在我内心深处。谈谈巨大的差异……我是说，我知道在《浅坟》和《猜火车》之间，还有《星球大战》的工作之间，有一堆工作。
There's tons of stuff you did in between there. But, I mean, the difference between probably what? Like a 28-day shoot on those earlier films, and then Star Wars, it'd take you probably a half a year to shoot those movies and working with green screens and all that kind of stuff. I mean, I would imagine your answer to which do you like better.
在那之间你做了很多事情。但是，我是说，可能是什么的区别？比如那些早期电影的28天拍摄，然后是《星球大战》，你可能需要半年时间来拍摄那些电影，并使用绿幕和所有那些东西。我是说，我想你对你更喜欢哪一个的回答。
You'd probably say, you know, little bits of each, but it's a totally different process, isn't it? It's a different process, and it teaches you that you're always challenged, aren't we? But every job we do, there's some challenge that it throws at you. And in those prequels, it was very much the challenge of, like, being...
你可能会说，你知道，每个的一点点，但这是一个完全不同的过程，不是吗？这是一个不同的过程，它教会你我们总是受到挑战，不是吗？但我们做的每一份工作，都有一些挑战抛给你。在那些前传里，它非常像是挑战，比如，成为……
Trying to be believable with this dialogue in front of a blue curtain, you know, for four months. Hey, is it true that George Lucas didn't give you guys the script until, like, two days before every scene or something like that? Is that true? No. Okay, thanks.
试图在蓝幕前用这些台词变得可信，你知道，持续四个月。嘿，乔治·卢卡斯是不是真的直到每一场戏前两天左右才给你们剧本之类的？那是真的吗？不。好的，谢谢。
It was one of those, you know, I had to go to the studio and sit in a room, sort of locked in to read it. Oh, I see. But we had the script. You know what made me laugh? It made me laugh so hard. I read somewhere, I saw you in an interview or something, saying you used the force, the Jedi force,
那是其中之一，你知道，我必须去工作室坐在一个房间里，被锁在里面阅读它。哦，我明白了。但我们有剧本。你知道什么让我笑了？它让我笑得太厉害了。我在某处读到，我在采访中看到你，或者类似的东西，说你使用原力，绝地原力，
to open automated doors at, like, supermarkets and stuff. But only if people are watching. If I think somebody's watching... I give it a little... You do a little, like, wave in front of the door. That is so funny. And don't get anything away here, just like... Now, you and you can go around to...
在超市之类的地方打开自动门。但只有在有人看的时候。如果我觉得有人在看……我给它一点……你做一点，比如，在门前挥手。那太搞笑了。别在这里泄露任何东西，就像……现在，你和你可以到处去……
You can go around to stores and supermarkets and movie theaters and stuff like that, or do you get tackled by fans and stuff, or do you just kind of get stopped and say, oh, hey, I really like your stuff, and would you take a picture and you kind of carry on? Yeah. Are they nuts because of all the Star Wars stuff?
你可以到处去商店、超市和电影院之类的地方，或者你会被粉丝扑倒之类的，还是你只是被拦住说，哦，嘿，我真的很喜欢你的作品，你会拍张照片然后继续走？是的。他们是因为所有的《星球大战》东西而疯狂吗？
Because of everything. Oh, and everything, but it made me laugh. Well, I... Yeah, I think it sounds really interesting. You've got this great level of fame, I think, like this perfect level of fame where you can... Your celebrity can get films financed and be a recruiting element for other cast elements
因为一切。哦，还有一切，但这让我笑了。嗯，我……是的，我觉得这听起来真的很有趣。你拥有这种伟大的名声水平，我想，就像这种完美的成名水平，你可以……你的名气可以为电影融资，并成为其他演员阵容的招募元素
and directors and stuff like that. You can still go out and have a... Yeah. You maybe could find some anonymity if you just kind of dress right, you know, you can... Yeah, I don't... I just tried to just do it, to do my life and not... Yeah, yeah.
和导演之类的。你仍然可以出去有一个……是的。你也许可以找到一些匿名性，如果你只是穿得对，你知道，你可以……是的，我没有……我只是试着去做，去过我的生活而不是……是的，是的。
To a point. And then there's a point. It's always... It's unavoidable when you're somewhere... You know, when you go to do press somewhere and they know the hotel you're staying in, and that's unavoidable. And I guess that...
到一定程度。然后有一个点。它总是……当你身处某地时是不可避免的……你知道，当你去某地做新闻，他们知道你住的酒店，那是不可避免的。我想那……
I have to learn to be better with that. Right. I'm not great with the autograph hunters who stand outside your hotel because I... I don't really believe they're... They're just trying to make money. They don't really want the autograph. They want to sell the autographs.
我必须学会更好地处理那个。对。我不擅长应付站在你酒店外面的签名猎人，因为我……我不相信他们是……他们只是想赚钱。他们并不真的想要签名。他们想卖掉签名。
Right. And I find that gets my eye are up a bit, but... Yeah. Now, wait, Jason... Can I just jump in and say my son, Abel, who's 11 years old, and I've never done this, but I'm going to put you on the spot, you and... He asked me to ask you.
对。我发现这让我的火气有点上来，但是……是的。现在，等等，杰森……我可以插一句说我的儿子，阿贝尔，他11岁，我从来没做过这个，但我会让你处于尴尬境地，你，伊万……他让我问你。
He was wondering, why did you accept the role of Obi-Wan Kenobi? Like, was there a reason besides the money? Yeah. That's amazing, Abel. Abel just texted me. Yeah. He just texted me.
他想知道，你为什么接受欧比旺·克诺比这个角色？比如，除了钱还有什么原因吗？是的。那太棒了，阿贝尔。阿贝尔刚给我发短信。是的。他刚给我发短信。
He texted you. Brilliant. That's hysterical. He asked me because he knew that you were on the show today and he is... He is... Again, he is such a massive fan, Abel. He is freaking out that you're here today.
他给你发短信了。太棒了。那太搞笑了。他问我是因为他知道你今天在节目上，而且他是……他是……再说一次，他是如此巨大的粉丝，阿贝尔。他因为你今天在这里而抓狂。
And he went... He left yesterday to go up and spend a couple days with his mom and he is like freaking out. He knew you were coming on today and then he just texted me that knowing that you're on now. That's cute. Well, I imagine you didn't probably
他昨天离开去和他妈妈待几天，他就像抓狂了。他知道你今天会来，然后他刚给我发短信，知道你现在在节目上。那很可爱。嗯，我想你可能不需要
even need to read the script, right? I mean, the yes was probably automatic, given... No, I really had to think about it because it came quite shortly after that trans-spotting period and really, by that time, I was so full of myself. You know, I was like this...
甚至不需要读剧本，对吧？我是说，那个“是”可能是自动的，考虑到……不，我真的必须考虑它，因为它出现在《猜火车》时期之后不久，真的，到那时，我太自以为是了。你知道，我当时就像这个……
I'm Danny Boyle's actor. I'm like fucking urban grunge. Here I go. I am the oasis of the British movie industry, you know? And then when the Star Wars came along, I thought, I don't know if I want to do this. This isn't me, you know? Right.
我是丹尼·博伊尔的演员。我就像他妈的城市垃圾。我来了。我是英国电影业的绿洲，你知道吗？然后当《星球大战》出现时，我想，我不知道我是否想做这个。这不是我，你知道吗？对。
And also, I worried about sort of... I suppose I was worried about typecasting or something like that or... Because you're going to be so famous from it. It's just going to be so big, I think. Yeah. And then I thought, well, I don't know. It didn't really...
而且我也担心某种……我想我担心被定型之类的，或者……因为你会因为这个而出名。我想它会变得非常大。是的。然后我想，嗯，我不知道。它并没有真正……
I was so into being the sort of anti-hero, if you like, you know? I live in America now, but for a long time I didn't and I thought, I'm going to do it, you know, like a indie British actor is what I felt like. And I felt, more than anything, I felt like I was Danny Boyle's actor and I felt that that sort of defined me.
我太沉迷于成为那种反英雄，如果你愿意的话，你知道吗？我现在住在美国，但很长一段时间我没有，我想，我要做它，你知道，就像一个独立英国演员是我感觉到的。而且我感觉，最重要的是，我觉得我是丹尼·博伊尔的演员，我觉得那定义了我。
I really did. And so I did... I asked everybody, I spoke to them. My uncle was in all three of the original ones. He played Wedge and Tillies, my uncle's an actor called Dennis Lawson. And I asked him and I said, what do you think?
我确实问了。所以我问了每个人，我和他们谈过。我叔叔出演了最初三部曲中的全部三部。他饰演了魏吉和提利斯，我叔叔是一位名叫丹尼斯·劳森的演员。我问他，我说，你觉得怎么样？
And he said, if you want a career after 30, don't do it. That's what he said. Oh, really? What did Danny Boyle say? Did you ask Danny Boyle? I did ask Danny Boyle, yeah. I think he said that I should do it. But in the end I just got closer and closer.
他说，如果你想在30岁以后还有职业生涯，就别演。他就是这么说的。哦，真的吗？丹尼·博伊尔怎么说？你问过丹尼·博伊尔吗？我确实问过丹尼·博伊尔，是的。我想他说我应该演。但最终我只是离它越来越近。
Like, the closer I got to it, I remember doing, you know, going to recalls and recalls and screen tests and then meeting George and it got down to like two or three of us, I think. And by that time I just thought, I just was so attached to the idea of it from when I was a kid that I thought, you know, to get a chance to be that character
就像，我离它越近，我记得我参加了复试、复试、试镜，然后见到了乔治，最后剩下我们两三个人，我想。到那时，我只是觉得，我从小就对这个想法非常执着，以至于我想，你知道，能有机会成为那个角色
and to be the younger Alec Guinness is pretty awesome. Yeah. But you were also signing up for what, three? Two or three? Three at a minimum? Yeah, three. But the other thing is like you asked your uncle, but the last thing you should do is ask another actor
并且成为年轻版的亚历克·吉尼斯真是太棒了。是的。但你当时也签了合同，是三部吗？两部还是三部？至少三部？是的，三部。但另一件事是，你问了你叔叔，但你最不该做的事就是问另一位演员
any advice on whether or not you should do something. I think it's like the worst thing to do because they can't help but put their own fucked up, you know, reasoning into it or their own desire or whatever. They can't help it. I remember one time... They didn't ask me to do it. Yeah, exactly.
关于你是否应该做某事的建议。我认为这是最糟糕的做法，因为他们忍不住会把他们自己那些乱七八糟的、你知道的、推理，或者他们自己的欲望之类的东西加进去。他们忍不住。我记得有一次……他们没让我演。是的，没错。
They didn't ask me. Right. And I wouldn't do it. I wouldn't do it. I remember years ago, years ago you were at the Golden Globes and I remember because Bradley Cooper at the time was, I think he was on Alias maybe.
他们没问我。对。而且我不会演。我不会演。我记得多年前，多年前你在金球奖颁奖典礼上，我记得是因为布莱德利·库珀当时，我想他可能在演《双面女间谍》。
And so he was there. He had gone and he was like, I'm going to the Golden Globes tonight. And we lived in the same... And so then he came back and he was like, man, he and I were just talking about this the other day because I told him you're on the show and he goes, man, I just saw Ewan McGregor was there tonight
所以他在那儿。他去了，他说，我今晚要去参加金球奖。我们住在同一个……然后他回来后，他说，伙计，我和他前几天还在谈论这件事，因为我告诉他你要上节目，他说，伙计，我今晚看到伊万·麦克格雷格在那儿
and he had like eyeliner on. And he was there and he goes, and he would look so fucking cool. And he's like, and we could never pull that off. We could never do that. And he was right. We were like fucking... You had eyeliner on at the globe?
他画了眼线。他在那儿，他说，他看起来太他妈酷了。他说，我们永远做不到那样。我们永远做不到。他是对的。我们当时就像他妈的……你在金球奖上画了眼线？
And he was so cool. Ewan was. And we were like, fuck man, we could never do this. I did that film Velvet Goldmine with Todd Haynes. And I just loved it. And I really always had this rock and roll fantasy, you know, that I probably still have a little bit that wouldn't it be amazing to be like a rock and roll
他太酷了。伊万是。我们当时想，该死，伙计，我们永远做不到这一点。我拍了托德·海因斯导演的那部电影《天鹅绒金矿》。我真的很喜欢它。我一直有一种摇滚幻想，你知道，我可能现在还有一点，如果能成为摇滚明星不是很棒吗
or on tour and stuff. And I don't think that... So for a while I did a war makeup and nail, you know, like nail varnish and stuff, but only for a little while. And I liked it. And I've always liked like, yeah, this isn't probably what you should do.
或者在巡演之类的。我不认为……所以有一段时间我化了战争妆，涂了指甲油之类的，但只持续了一小会儿。我喜欢它。我一直喜欢，是的，这可能不是你应该做的。
So I'm going to do it, you know, at the globes. Maybe it's not the best. I know me. By the way, you pulled it off. It was very cool. And I get it too, because you just... I'm also a contrarian, I think, by nature. And I'm always like, if everybody else is doing it,
所以我打算在金球奖上这么做。也许这不是最好的。我了解我自己。顺便说一句，你成功驾驭了它。非常酷。我也理解，因为你只是……我想我天生也是个唱反调的人。我总是觉得，如果其他人都在做这件事，
then that means I absolutely cannot do that thing. Often to my own, you know, disservice or whatever. You know, it's not always the best thing, but I don't know if... I'm sensing that there's a little bit of that in you as well. I know. There's definitely... I'm like that with movies that are hugely successful.
那就意味着我绝对不能做那件事。通常这对我自己是有害的，或者什么的。你知道，这并不总是最好的事情，但我不知道……我感觉到你身上也有那么一点点这种特质。我知道。绝对有……我对那些非常成功的电影也是这样。
I'm like, well, I'm not going to watch it. You know, and then I see it eight years later and I'm like, that film's really good. It's like, yeah. Right, right. Yeah, that film was really good eight years ago. I know. I do the same thing.
我会说，好吧，我才不看呢。你知道，然后八年后我看了，我就想，那部电影真不错。就像，是的。对，对。是的，那部电影八年前就很好。我知道。我也做同样的事。
I do that with movies. I do that with TV shows. I was like, hey, man, during the pandemic, I was like, have you guys seen The American Office? It's really good. And I'm friends with a lot of people on the show. I'm friends. Like Krasinski and I had to be like,
我对待电影是这样。我对待电视节目也是这样。我当时说，嘿，伙计，在疫情期间，我说，你们看过美版《办公室》吗？它真的很棒。我和剧组里的很多人都是朋友。我是朋友。比如克拉辛斯基，我不得不说，
I actually never watched it. I'm like, it's really, really good. I did that with Breaking Bad. Breaking Bad, I watched like two years ago. I feel like I'm going to be saying that about the Sopranos when I get that watch. Yeah, I've never seen the Sopranos. I did that.
我其实从来没看过。我说，它真的，真的很好。我对待《绝命毒师》也是这样。《绝命毒师》，我大概两年前才看。我觉得当我看完《黑道家族》时，我也会这么说。是的，我从来没看过《黑道家族》。我做过。
The Sopranos was my one years later. Years and years later. Did you not watch it? Not yet. It's really good. Like one here or one there? Yeah. You and this is a true story.
《黑道家族》是我多年后才看的。多年又多年之后。你没看吗？还没。它真的很棒。比如看一集或者两集？是的。你和这是一个真实的故事。
One day, when Jason and I were working together years ago, he came after a weekend and he goes, hey, you know, this is a true story. He goes, hey, you know, Blues Brothers is pretty good. And I go, this is like 2004. 2004 and I go, Blues Brothers, the 1978 film? Yeah, it's pretty good. I just figured everyone had sort of missed it.
有一天，当杰森和我多年前一起工作时，他周末过后过来，他说，嘿，你知道，这是一个真实的故事。他说，嘿，你知道，《蓝调兄弟》相当不错。我说，这大概是2004年。2004年，我说，《蓝调兄弟》，1978年的那部电影？是的，它相当不错。我只是觉得每个人都错过了它。
Like me. Everyone's like me, right? There's so many of us. That's a narcissist, Captain Narcissism in me. That's just terrible. That's terrible. That's funny. Ewan, where did the motorcycle passion come from?
像我一样。每个人都像我，对吧？我们有很多人。那是自恋者，我心中的自恋队长。那真是太糟糕了。那太糟糕了。真有趣。伊万，你对摩托车的热情是从哪里来的？
I've always ridden motorbikes since I was, well, no, I wanted to ride motorbikes since I was a teenager and my parents would never let me. And so it was just after I finished drama school, I realized that I could do what I wanted, you know. And so I got my first little motorbike in London. And I used to park outside and when they came to visit me, there was a lovely girl upstairs called Elska.
我一直骑摩托车，自从我，嗯，不，我从十几岁起就想骑摩托车，但我父母从来不让我骑。所以就在我戏剧学校毕业后，我意识到我可以做我想做的事，你知道。所以我买了我在伦敦的第一辆小摩托车。我过去常把它停在外面，当他们来看我时，楼上有一个可爱的女孩叫艾尔斯卡。
I used to take all my stuff up to my riding gear, my helmets and gloves and I'd stash them in her place so they wouldn't see them, you know. And pretend that, anyway, that went on for a while. And I started riding, I just love it. I still love it as much as I ever did. And I started, I rode everywhere in London. I'd use it to get about and I'd go for trips on it.
我过去常把我的东西，我的骑行装备、头盔和手套都拿上去，藏在她那里，这样他们就看不到了，你知道。假装，总之，那持续了一段时间。我开始骑车，我只是喜欢它。我仍然像以前一样喜欢它。我开始在伦敦到处骑。我用它代步，还骑着它去旅行。
And I met my great mate Charlie Bormann when we made a film together called Serpent's Kiss in Ireland. And we'd both just had babies and we were both into bikes. He'd grew up riding motorbikes. And so we just sort of, we did a lot of track days together and we were involved in a race team, not riding, but we were sort of the sort of glam squad for this little motorcycle racing team.
我在爱尔兰拍摄电影《毒吻》时认识了我的好哥们查理·伯曼。我们俩刚有了孩子，我们都喜欢摩托车。他从小就骑摩托车。所以我们只是，我们一起参加了很多赛道日，我们参与了一个赛车队，不是骑手，但我们算是这个小型摩托车赛车队的魅力小分队。
Like road bikes? Road bikes, yeah, like track racing. Wow. And then I read this book written by Ted Simon who wrote a beautiful book called Jupiter's Travels in the 70s and he was a journalist, I think for the Sunday Times, and he decided he wanted to travel the world
像公路摩托车？公路摩托车，是的，像赛道比赛。哇。然后我读了泰德·西蒙写的一本书，他在70年代写了一本很棒的书叫《朱庇特的旅行》，他是一位记者，我想是为《星期日泰晤士报》工作的，他决定他想环游世界
and he wasn't a biker, but he just thought that's the best way to see the world. And he's right, it really is the best way. There's something about it. So he wrote this, he got a triumph and he rode around the world and it took him four and a half years. And his book started, he starts like three and a half years in
他不是个骑手，但他只是觉得那是看世界最好的方式。他是对的，这确实是最好的方式。它有一种特别之处。所以他写了这本书，他买了一辆凯旋摩托车，骑着它环游世界，花了四年半的时间。他的书开头，他从三年半后开始写
and he's run out of petrol and he's sitting underneath a tree in India somewhere and his bike's propped up there because he's got no gas. And he just said, I'm sitting here safe in the knowledge that someone will come and help. And that's sort of how the book starts. And it had taken him three years to realize
他没油了，坐在印度某处的一棵树下，他的摩托车靠在那里，因为他没油了。他只是说，我坐在这里，心中确信会有人来帮忙。这就是书的开头方式。他花了三年时间才意识到
that that was a truth, you know. And there's something beautiful about his writing in the book and it's just sort of boiled away in the back of my brain. Until one day I was thinking of, Charlie and I were always talking about looking for somewhere to ride and we thought we'd go to Spain from London
那是事实，你知道。他的书里有一种美妙的东西，它只是在我脑海深处慢慢发酵。直到有一天我在想，查理和我一直在谈论寻找骑行的地方，我们想从伦敦去西班牙
on some sports tours and we'd take our wives on the back and then maybe they could fly home and we'll race back. And I just started thinking, well, I don't know, and then I would start looking further afield and I got a world map and I looked at, I thought we could go to China and back.
骑一些运动旅行车，我们带上我们的妻子，然后也许她们可以飞回家，我们再骑车赶回来。我只是开始想，嗯，我不知道，然后我会开始看得更远，我拿了一张世界地图，我看了看，我想我们可以去中国再回来。
That would be cool. And then I thought, well, what would just come back along the same route? And so I kept looking right on the map and it was sort of a direct line around to America and, you know, Canada and I just thought, well, we could do that.
那会很酷。然后我想，嗯，为什么要沿着同样的路线回来？所以我一直看着地图，那是一条直接绕到美国，你知道，加拿大，我只是想，嗯，我们可以那样做。
So that was our first trip in 2004. Wait, you went all the way around the world? We went from, well, it's officially not around the world trip because it's only the northern hemisphere, but we rode from London round to New York. So we rode from London. Oh my God.
所以那是我们2004年的第一次旅行。等等，你们环游了世界？我们从，嗯，这在官方上不是环球旅行，因为它只是北半球，但我们从伦敦骑到了纽约。所以我们从伦敦出发。天哪。
And we went in the channel tunnel to France and then we rode to far eastern Russia and Siberia. And then we got a plane with the bikes to Anchorage and then we rode from Anchorage to New York. And that was like four and a half months and we shot it. We shot it as a documentary with this amazing journalistic cameraman, Claudio von Planter,
我们穿过英吉利海峡隧道去了法国，然后骑到了俄罗斯远东和西伯利亚。然后我们带着摩托车坐飞机去了安克雷奇，然后我们从安克雷奇骑到了纽约。那大概是四个半月，我们拍摄了它。我们把它拍成了一部纪录片，由这位了不起的纪实摄影师克劳迪奥·冯·普兰特拍摄，
who's our guy and he just rode with us. Big name. So a third bike. That was a three bikes. And then we had a couple of pickup trucks that we saw once in a while and we'd, you know, and then we did Africa. We did the whole African continent in 2007
他是我们的人，他只是和我们一起骑行。大人物。所以是第三辆摩托车。那是三辆摩托车。然后我们有几辆皮卡车，我们偶尔会见到，我们，你知道，然后我们去了非洲。我们在2007年完成了整个非洲大陆的骑行
and we did from Terrell Del Fuego, which is the tip of South America to Los Angeles and just before the pandemic in 2019 on electric bikes on the electric. I saw footage of that where you guys were in Chile, I think, going across the flat. In those electric bikes. That's pretty cool.
我们从南美洲尖端的火地岛骑到了洛杉矶，就在2019年疫情之前，骑的是电动摩托车。我看到了那段录像，我想你们在智利，穿过平原。骑着那些电动摩托车。那太酷了。
They're all on Apple. There's three documentaries, Long Way Round, Long Way Down and Long Way Up. That's the order to watch them. Oh my God. That's pretty cool. That's great. I have a question.
它们都在苹果上。有三部纪录片，《长路漫漫》、《长路迢迢》和《长路向上》。那是观看顺序。天哪。那太酷了。太棒了。我有一个问题。
Do you... Okay, go ahead, sir. And state your name first. Where are you calling from? But do you and Jason, do you guys ever get mistaken for each other because I always thought you guys kind of look similarly? I've always thought that.
你……好吧，请说，先生。先报上你的名字。你从哪里打来的？但是你和杰森，你们俩会被认错吗？因为我一直觉得你们长得有点像？我一直这么认为。
My wife wants us to play brothers forever. Me too. I've always said that. I've always said that. Because you're beautiful, Ewan. You're really, really handsome. What a compliment to Jason, that is. That's an incredible compliment to Jason.
我妻子希望我们永远演兄弟。我也是。我一直这么说。我一直这么说。因为你很帅，伊万。你真的，真的很帅。这对杰森来说真是个恭维。这对杰森来说是一个不可思议的恭维。
No, I see it. I definitely am, no. Ewan, do you feel like playing his much younger brother? Let's do it. No, I would definitely play his kid brother. Twins. You know, just sort of like, hey... Jay, you could be his dad almost.
不，我看得出来，我绝对是，不。伊万，你觉得演他年轻很多的弟弟怎么样？来吧。不，我绝对会演他的弟弟。双胞胎。你知道，只是那种，嘿……杰，你几乎可以当他爸爸了。
I sort of got... Will, can I talk to you for a second? Move your camera a little bit. I think we should put it out there, Jason. It should happen, don't you think? Yes, please. We should do some... I'm ready.
我有点……威尔，我能跟你说句话吗？把你的摄像机挪一点。我觉得我们应该把它说出来，杰森。这应该发生，你不觉得吗？是的，拜托。我们应该做一些……我准备好了。
Indie brothers thing. Ewan, how's your American accent? Is it quite good? I think it's okay. Of course it's good. I think it's all right. It's been working this whole life. I've worked with Liz Hemmelstein.
独立兄弟那种事。伊万，你的美国口音怎么样？还不错吗？我觉得还可以。当然很好。我觉得还可以。我这辈子都在用它。我和利兹·赫梅尔斯坦合作过。
Did anyone work with Liz Hemmelstein? No. Well, you probably don't have to work with someone with your American accents, but I do. Well, I'm Canadian. I had to work with... Will, wait. Did you really work on getting rid of your outs and abouts?
有人和利兹·赫梅尔斯坦合作过吗？没有。好吧，你可能不需要和别人一起练习你的美国口音，但我需要。好吧，我是加拿大人。我不得不和……威尔，等等。你真的努力去掉了你的“out”和“about”的口音吗？
No, I didn't. Out and about? Out and about? No, I did, but there were certain things that I just tried to get rid of. Oh, sure. Then I didn't go up at the end of every sentence. You didn't have to take the question mark off every sentence. Yeah.
不，我没有。Out and about？Out and about？不，我确实去掉了，但有些东西我只是试着去掉。哦，当然。然后我没有在每句话结尾都上扬。你不需要在每句话后面都去掉问号。是的。
I didn't say house. But I used to do... I used to... It's an absolutely brutal day for motor car racing. That's good. I used to do that. Is that Jackie Stewart? Do you do Jackie Stewart?
我没说“house”。但我过去常做……我过去常……这对赛车来说是绝对残酷的一天。那很好。我过去常那样做。那是杰基·斯图尔特吗？你模仿杰基·斯图尔特吗？
Yeah, it's Jackie Stewart. It's Jackie Stewart. Jackie Stewart. He's still knocking about. He's still at all the races, Jackie. Is he? He's still around. He seems to be very present.
是的，是杰基·斯图尔特。是杰基·斯图尔特。杰基·斯图尔特。他还在到处转悠。他还在所有的比赛中，杰基。是吗？他还在。他似乎非常活跃。
Now, are you a golf fan? No, I just was interested in your outfit. Your golfing outfit that you were discussing at the beginning with the funny trouser thing at the front. It wasn't bad. How do you... Do you all play golf? Sean does not.
现在，你是高尔夫球迷吗？不，我只是对你的装束感兴趣。你刚才在开头讨论的那套高尔夫装束，前面有那种滑稽的裤子。还不赖。你们怎么……你们都打高尔夫吗？肖恩不打。
Will and I do. Jason and I do, yeah. You do? Yeah. Do you play any at all? I grew up playing because I was a... Because in Scotland everybody plays. And then I just...
威尔和我打。杰森和我打，是的。你们打？是的。你打吗？我从小就打，因为我是……因为在苏格兰每个人都打。然后我只是……
I've done it from time to time. And I can never get over the fact that I'm not as good as I think I am. So... You always end up in horrible mood. Is that just the way it is? That's all of us. But then, you know, Roy McElroy, he says, don't let golf affect your attitude. Let your attitude affect your golf.
我时不时会打。我永远无法克服这样一个事实，那就是我没有我想象中那么好。所以……你总是以糟糕的心情结束。这就是现状吗？我们都一样。但你知道，罗伊·麦克罗伊，他说，不要让高尔夫影响你的态度。让你的态度影响你的高尔夫。
Oh. You know? Okay, that's good. Sean. Oh. I think I... I think I'm good at golf if I could just get out of my way. I think I'd probably...
哦。你知道吗？好吧，那很好。肖恩。哦。我想我……我想如果我能克服自己的心理障碍，我打高尔夫会很好。我想我可能会……
No, you stick to motorcycles and rock and roll. You're a stud. You're a man's man. Will and I, you know, we're just golfers, you know? Yeah, we're delicate golfers. Here, it's different. I feel like it's different. There's a sort of...
不，你还是坚持骑摩托车和摇滚吧。你是个硬汉。你是个纯爷们。威尔和我，你知道，我们只是高尔夫球手，你知道？是的，我们是脆弱的高尔夫球手。这里，情况不同。我觉得它不同。有一种……
I don't know if it's different. I was always struck me as being different here. And Britain, it seems to be a little bit... Feels a bit more elitist and... Here, it's elitist. Here, I feel like everybody plays golf and, you know, golf clubs are... I don't know because the big golf clubs here in LA are so expensive, aren't they? Like, you have to be...
我不知道它是否不同。我一直觉得它在这里很不同。在英国，它似乎有点……感觉更精英主义，而且……在这里，它是精英主义。在这里，我觉得每个人都打高尔夫，而且，你知道，高尔夫俱乐部是……我不知道，因为洛杉矶的大高尔夫俱乐部太贵了，不是吗？比如，你必须是……
Yeah, it's a real status thing. I'm not proud of it. I just love the game. Yeah, I will say this. I think the thing that I struggle with the most with golf are a lot of the people who do play golf. And I'm sure we're going to get a lot of pushback from people online. From the golfing community.
是的，这真的是一种身份象征。我不以此为荣。我只是喜欢这项运动。是的，我会说这个。我认为我在高尔夫中最挣扎的事情是很多打高尔夫的人。我相信我们会在网上收到很多反对意见。来自高尔夫社区。
And now we've enraged the heroin addicts and now the golfing community. And if they ever got together... There should be a golf championship for heroin addicts. And that would be... They just fall asleep as they're putting... It would be amazing. But you do have... It does...
现在我们激怒了海洛因成瘾者，现在又激怒了高尔夫社区。如果他们聚在一起……应该为海洛因成瘾者举办高尔夫锦标赛。那会是……他们只是在推杆时睡着了……那会很棒。但你确实有……它确实……
There is that sort of part of golf that does have this very sort of elitist and kind of exclusionary feel and vibe to it and people who are completely out of touch. And so you never want to become that. That's the part that I don't like. Yeah, but I mean it's like... If you're like doing it like who don't, right? No, I know. Of course.
高尔夫确实有那种非常精英主义和排他性的感觉和氛围，还有那些完全脱离现实的人。所以你永远不想成为那样的人。那是我不喜欢的部分。是的，但我的意思是……如果你像那样做，谁不呢，对吧？不，我知道。当然。
Of course. But you just hope that you don't become that, you know? I think you're right. I think that seems to be like the golf club side of things. Yes. And then... Because the idea of being part of a club lends itself to that anyway, doesn't it? It's something you have to pay into to be feel special at your club.
当然。但你只是希望你不要成为那样，你知道？我想你是对的。我想那似乎就是高尔夫俱乐部那一面的东西。是的。然后……因为成为俱乐部一部分的想法本身就倾向于那样，不是吗？这是你需要付费才能在你的俱乐部感到特别的东西。
But the actual game of golf when you're on the beautiful fairway is an amazing game. It's really challenging and no question. I mean, Will, do I grind or what? I mean, I'm out there just trying to really shoot a low number. He's not even really fun to play with anymore. No, not at all. Oh, you're too serious about it? Yeah, way too serious.
但当你走在美丽的球道上时，真正的高尔夫比赛是一项了不起的运动。它真的很有挑战性，毫无疑问。我的意思是，威尔，我努力吗？我的意思是，我在外面只是想真正打出一个低杆数。他甚至不再是一个有趣的球友了。不，一点也不。哦，你对它太认真了？是的，太认真了。
Well, yeah, but I'm just... I'm only out there for the challenge of it. And the slowest golfer in California. I'm speeding up. I'm trying to get faster. You are speeding up. You are getting better. If there's someone behind me on the tee waiting, I get so stressed.
嗯，是的，但我只是……我只是为了挑战才去那里的。而且是加州打球最慢的高尔夫球手。我正在加快速度。我正在努力变快。你确实在加快速度。你确实在变好。如果发球台后面有人在等，我会感到压力很大。
Just on his hip. Oh, don't worry. He doesn't get stressed. I tried golfing in Ireland once with my brother. Did you? Yeah, one of my friends, my brother, Kevin, I played golf with him in Ireland and they didn't have carts. So I had to carry our bags everywhere and I said, I'm out.
就在他屁股后面。哦，别担心。他不会感到压力。我曾经在爱尔兰和我哥哥打过一次高尔夫。你打过吗？是的，我的一个朋友，我哥哥凯文，我在爱尔兰和他打过高尔夫，他们没有球车。所以我不得不随身携带我们的包，我说，我不玩了。
And then I golfed... Wait, that's when you came out? Oh, oh, you're out of... Sorry. On a golf club in Ireland? Wow. I'm out. Seems like a good start.
然后我打了……等等，那是你出柜的时候吗？哦，哦，你出……抱歉。在爱尔兰的高尔夫俱乐部？哇。我不玩了。看起来是个好的开始。
Jesus Christ. I just screamed it. I screamed it. So wait, how come we haven't heard of Kevin before? How many siblings do you have, Sean? I signed for Tracy. I signed for Kevin. Mike, who passed away sadly, my sister Tracy and me.
天哪。我刚才尖叫出来了。我尖叫出来了。等等，为什么我们之前没听说过凯文？你有几个兄弟姐妹，肖恩？我签了特雷西。我签了凯文。迈克，他不幸去世了，我的妹妹特雷西和我。
Kevin, you, Tracy. And Dennis. And Dennis. Dennis is no longer with us. No, Mike. No, Mike passed away. Michael. You've been friends with Jeff for a long time, by the way.
凯文，你，特雷西。还有丹尼斯。还有丹尼斯。丹尼斯已经不在了。不，迈克。不，迈克去世了。迈克尔。顺便说一句，你和杰夫做朋友很久了。
This is embarrassing for you. Will, Will, why don't you tell me the name of your brother real quick? Chuck. That's pretty fast. You're getting faster. My other sister is here. She has a Scottish name. Her name is Shanley.
这对你来说很尴尬。威尔，威尔，你为什么不快点告诉我你哥哥的名字？查克。那很快。你变快了。我的另一个妹妹在这里。她有一个苏格兰名字。她叫尚利。
And the other one is Tennis. Tennis. Tennis. Tennis. That's my job. And then I played golf with Jimmy Burroughs, who was on our podcast. Great golfer. And Alan Thicke, who sadly passed away as well.
另一个是网球。网球。网球。网球。那是我的工作。然后我和吉米·伯罗斯打了高尔夫，他上过我们的播客。很棒的高尔夫球手。还有艾伦·锡克，他也不幸去世了。
But that was really fun. That was in Cabos and Lucas. That was, and I did really well. Okay. You and McGregor's with us. And he's joining us from a very handsome kitchen. Where is your house there, Ewan? I'm in my, this is my, I'm down in my little, I'm in my tiny house.
但那真的很有趣。那是在卡波圣卢卡斯。那是，我表现得很好。好的。伊万·麦克格雷格和我们在一起。他从一个非常漂亮的厨房加入我们。你的房子在哪里，伊万？我在我的，这是我的，我在我的小房子里。
I've got a little tiny house in my, in my garden. Looks handsome. I do, it's just like quiet in here because there's no one in here. So. Are you in California? I'm in California. Yeah. Yeah.
我在我的花园里有一个小房子。看起来很帅。我确实有，这里很安静，因为这里没有人。所以。你在加州吗？我在加州。是的。是的。
We'll be right back. All right. Back to the show. So you're, you've lived in America for a long time. You're like five years, six years? Yeah. I moved here in 2008. Okay.
我们马上回来。好的。回到节目。所以你，你在美国住了很长时间。你大概五年，六年了？是的。我2008年搬到这里。好的。
And I became an American two years ago. Welcome. Welcome. I love it here. Yeah. Thank you. I just love it. I love living here and I, no intention to not live here.
我两年前成为了美国人。欢迎。欢迎。我喜欢这里。是的。谢谢。我只是喜欢它。我喜欢住在这里，而且我，没有打算不住在这里。
I just love it. I love it. What was that process like? What did, what did you have to know? You have to know like the, the, the, the, the Star Spangled Banner or basic history or how does that go? It's a bit, well I, I'm a, it's probably a bit like a driving test, you know, when you learn all this stuff and then as soon as you, as soon as they say you can drive
我只是喜欢它。我喜欢它。那个过程是什么样的？你必须知道什么？你必须知道比如，星条旗，或者基本历史，或者它是怎么进行的？它有点，嗯，我，我是一个，它可能有点像驾驶考试，你知道，当你学习所有这些东西，然后一旦你，一旦他们说你可以开车
a car, you forget all of it. So it's a lot of American history. How the political system works here, which is difficult for a bridge because it's quite complicated, it seems. And then some of, you've got to know names of like your local. Oh, senators and then congressmen. Yeah. Congress people, senators and stuff like that.
一辆车，你就把它们全忘了。所以这是很多美国历史。这里的政治制度是如何运作的，这对英国人来说很难，因为它看起来很复杂。然后一些，你必须知道名字，比如你当地的。哦，参议员，还有国会议员。是的。国会议员，参议员之类的。
Yeah. They ask you dates and stuff. They ask you dates of like when things were written and what have you. Oh wow. I did it in 2007. I became, I did the same thing and I remember they did the thing you had to, you had to remember which were the original 13 states, et cetera, and all those sort of things. So I studied.
是的。他们问你日期之类的。他们问你日期，比如事情是什么时候写的，等等。哦，哇。我2007年做的。我成为了，我做了同样的事情，我记得他们做了你必须做的，你必须记住最初的13个州是什么，等等，所有那些事情。所以我学习了。
I wanted to be, I wanted to get a hundred percent and the guy, it's really up to the discretion of the person who, who's giving you the, that final interview, right? It was anyway back then. And the guy goes, he starts asking me a couple of questions and then he could see that I knew what I was, I knew what the answers were. He's like, okay, well you got this and he moves on. I was like, no, no, no. You're not moving on.
我想成为，我想拿到满分，那个人，这真的取决于给你最后面试的那个人，对吧？反正当时是这样。那个人开始问我几个问题，然后他能看出我知道答案是什么。他说，好吧，你通过了，然后他继续往下问。我说，不，不，不。你不能继续。
I studied this. Yeah. Yeah. Right? Yeah. I had the same thing because you have to get 10 questions. No, you have to get six questions right out of 10. Yeah.
我学习了这个。是的。是的。对吧？是的。我有同样的情况，因为你必须答对10个问题。不，你必须答对10个问题中的6个。是的。
And I got, I got six right. Yeah. It's like a hundred, I think there's a hundred potential questions and they ask you 10 and you have to get at least six of them right. And so once you get six of them right, they go, okay, that's it. And I was like, I was like, you, I was like, no, no, what are the other four? I spent a lot of time learning this stuff, you know. Yeah.
我答对了6个。是的。我想有100个潜在问题，他们问你10个，你必须至少答对6个。所以一旦你答对6个，他们就说，好吧，就这样。我说，我说，你，我说，不，不，另外四个是什么？我花了很多时间学习这些东西，你知道。是的。
Now, you and McGregor, talk to me about your domestic situation there. You got, you got one kid, two kids, one wife, boyfriend. It doesn't matter. This is a real liberal show. I, I'm, I'm recently married. I married this year to my love, Mary Elizabeth Winston. Congratulations. You got married this year?
现在，伊万·麦克格雷格，跟我说说你的家庭情况。你有一个孩子，两个孩子，一个妻子，男朋友。没关系。这是一个非常自由的节目。我，我最近结婚了。我今年和我爱的人，玛丽·伊丽莎白·温斯顿结婚了。恭喜。你今年结婚了？
I got married this year. Nice. I have four, four daughters with my ex-wife, Ev. Yeah. And we, and Mary and I have a one year old son. So I have five children. Oh, that's amazing. Yeah.
我今年结婚了。不错。我和前妻伊芙有四个女儿。是的。玛丽和我有一个一岁的儿子。所以我有五个孩子。哦，那太棒了。是的。
Yeah. So I'm really lucky and very much in love and I'm very, very happy and. How old's your son? I'm blessed with all my kids. He's just turned one. Wow. Okay. I have a, I have a two year old.
是的。所以我真的很幸运，非常相爱，我非常，非常快乐。你儿子多大了？我有福气拥有我所有的孩子。他刚满一岁。哇。好的。我有一个，我有一个两岁的孩子。
I have two older boys from my first, and I have a two year old as well. Yeah. How old are your girls? My eldest girl, Clara is 26. Yeah. My 20 year olds, Esther and Jamian and my youngest daughter, Anook is 11. Oh, great. All ages.
我有两个来自第一次婚姻的大儿子，我也有一个两岁的孩子。是的。你的女儿们多大了？我的大女儿克拉拉26岁。是的。我的20岁女儿埃丝特和杰米安，我最小的女儿阿努克11岁。哦，太棒了。各个年龄段。
Yeah. I just, I love it so much. I love it so much being a dad. I really do. Dad, did you think you were going to love it as much as you did? Or, I mean, I thought, yeah, this is going to be cool. And then I'm, now I'm just like up, just a baby. I mean, I cry watching commercials if there's a little kid in it.
是的。我只是，我太喜欢它了。我太喜欢当爸爸了。我真的喜欢。爸爸，你以为你会像现在这样喜欢它吗？或者，我的意思是，我想，是的，这会很酷。然后我，现在我只是，只是一个婴儿。我的意思是，如果广告里有小孩，我会看哭的。
I just love it. I think I do. I think I was totally old. Yeah. I was, I had Clara when I was 24 years old. Yeah. And I was just always, I always knew that I wanted children and I just, and I really, I really love it.
我只是喜欢它。我想我做到了。我想我完全老了。是的。我在24岁时有了克拉拉。是的。我一直，我一直知道我想要孩子，我只是，我真的，我真的很喜欢它。
I really do. It really makes me incredibly happy. Now, quick math there. That puts you at 50? 51. 51. When's your birthday? What time are you?
我真的喜欢。它真的让我非常快乐。现在，快速算一下。那让你50岁了？51岁。51岁。你生日是什么时候？你是什么时候？
Sorry, I'm asking for a friend. And then I want to know what your rising is. What are you? I'm born on the end of, I was the last day of March, 31st of March, 1971. So I'm in Aries. Aries. Where are you guys at? What, what ages are we here in there?
抱歉，我是替朋友问的。然后我想知道你的上升星座是什么。你是什么？我出生在月底，3月31日，1971年。所以我是一个白羊座。白羊座。你们在哪里？我们在这里是什么年龄？
Oh, I'm just 35, but I think that we should move on. Will doesn't, Will can't play older than 40. I skew 30. I skew late 30s, but, but I, I'm 50. I'm 52. Sean and I are both 52. We're only a couple of weeks apart. I'm 53.
哦，我刚35岁，但我认为我们应该继续。威尔不，威尔不能演超过40岁的角色。我偏向30岁。我偏向30多岁后期，但是，但是，我50岁。我52岁。肖恩和我都是52岁。我们只差几周。我53岁。
I'm the adult here. Okay. Yeah. Growing up. That's why you're so good at golf because you're just a bit older than us. Yeah. But I just don't hit it as far anymore. Because I've seen, I think everything you've ever done.
我是这里的成年人。好的。是的。成长。这就是为什么你高尔夫打得那么好，因为你比我们大一点。是的。但我只是打得没那么远了。因为我看过，我想你做过的每一件事。
By the way, also audition for down with love still. I didn't get that. Oh yeah. And this make-a-wish is going great with you. Great average. But tell me what it's like, cause you, didn't you do, are you in Pinocchio coming out? Are you in it? Yeah.
顺便说一句，也试镜了《爱不设防》，还没得到那个角色。哦，是的。这个“许愿”和你一起进行得很顺利。很棒的平均水平。但告诉我那是什么感觉，因为你，你不是拍了，你演了即将上映的《匹诺曹》吗？你在里面吗？是的。
Or like you, do you voice it or you're in it? I voice it. It's totally stop frame animation. Wow. And that's Guillermo del Toro. Yeah. Yeah. It's embarrassing.
或者像你，你是配音还是你在里面？我配音。它是完全的定格动画。哇。那是吉尔莫·德尔·托罗。是的。是的。这很尴尬。
It was, I had an experience. I don't know if you've ever done this. It's sort of an actor's nightmare of being in a situation where you're absolutely unprepared. And that's what happened with this. I went to meet Guillermo and I thought to discuss the role and to discuss what we were going to do with it. And I arrived and I was in a sound studio with in front of a mic with a lectern with the script on there.
那是，我有过一次经历。我不知道你有没有做过这个。这是一种演员的噩梦，处于一种你完全没有准备好的情况。这就是发生在这部电影上的事。我去见吉尔莫，我以为是讨论角色，讨论我们要怎么做。我到了，我在一个录音棚里，麦克风前有一个讲台，上面有剧本。
And he's behind the glass. And I was going, okay, let's start off with Q1. What? And I hadn't read the script because I just thought we were having a chat. So I was busy and I hadn't read it. And I started trying to do it. I just didn't tell him. And I thought, I'll just, I just have to go.
他在玻璃后面。我说，好吧，让我们从Q1开始。什么？我没读过剧本，因为我以为我们只是在聊天。所以我很忙，没读过。我开始试着做。我只是没告诉他。我想，我只是，我必须去。
So I was started. And of course I had an idea of who Jiminy Cricket was, but it didn't seem to be anything like what I was reading on the page. And I didn't know what accent to use or what I, I, I almost was crying. I just got to the point where I wanted to cry, you know, I was so embarrassed. And I just asked him to come in the room after about 20, I did about 25 minutes of this nightmare. So he comes round into the room and I went, look, I was really tearing up. And I went, I have to tell you, I haven't read the script.
所以我开始了。当然，我对吉米尼蟋蟀是谁有个概念，但它看起来和我读到的页面上的任何东西都不一样。我不知道该用什么口音，或者我，我，我几乎要哭了。我只是到了那种我想哭的地步，你知道，我太尴尬了。在大约20分钟的噩梦后，我只是让他进房间。所以我绕到房间里，我说，看，我真的要哭了。我说，我必须告诉你，我没读过剧本。
I wasn't, I wasn't sent it. I thought we were having a discussion about, and it turned out, thank God I hadn't been sent it, although I didn't know that for absolute sure. But anyway, then we just, he was just great cause he just went, no, what, what are you doing is good. And, and he talked to me for about half an hour and then we just went and we recorded the whole thing. No way.
我没，我没收到它。我以为我们在讨论，结果，感谢上帝我没收到它，虽然我不能百分之百确定。但总之，然后我们只是，他太棒了，因为他只是说，不，你正在做的是好的。然后，他和我谈了大约半小时，然后我们就去录了整件事。没门。
And then I read it and we went back in. So it's been one of those things, you've probably all done them when you go back several times you go in and out. And, but I think it's going to be really, I love him and I love his take on things. And so to be involved in this is really cool. Yeah. Well, explain the whole, Will wants to do some voiceover work. We're talking through the process of it.
然后我读了它，我们又回去了。所以这是那种事情之一，你们可能都做过，当你回去好几次，进进出出。但是，我认为它会非常，我爱他，我爱他对事情的看法。所以能参与其中真的很酷。是的。好吧，解释一下整个过程，威尔想做一些配音工作。我们正在讨论这个过程。
So the crazy story. Did I, I told you guys this story about when I did Ratatouille, right? Did I tell you guys this? I didn't know you were in there. I was in there. Yeah. And Brad Bird directed. So similar thing.
所以那个疯狂的故事。我告诉过你们我拍《料理鼠王》时的那个故事吗，对吧？我告诉过你们吗？我不知道你在里面。我在里面。是的。布拉德·伯德导演的。所以类似的事情。
So I get a call. This is crazy that you just told the story. When was that? That was like at least 15 years ago, maybe more. We were doing, we were, we were still doing a rest of development, original, the rest of development at the time. He goes, they sent me the thing and they go, you're going to go up to Disney to record this stuff.
所以我接到一个电话。你刚才讲的故事太疯狂了。那是什么时候？那大概是至少15年前，也许更多。我们当时正在，我们正在，我们当时还在做《发展受阻》，最初的《发展受阻》。他说，他们把东西寄给我，他们说，你要去迪士尼录这些东西。
And I'm like, great. Yeah, no problem. I get up there. I guess it sent me materials, but I'm not sure either I didn't see it or ignored it or whatever. And I was not prepared for what I was walking into. Same thing. Walk into a soundstage, into a recording studio at Disney.
我说，太棒了。是的，没问题。我到了那里。我想它寄给我材料了，但我也不确定，要么我没看到，要么忽略了，或者什么的。我没有为我即将走进的东西做好准备。同样的事情。走进一个摄影棚，走进迪士尼的一个录音室。
He, Brad's there. And he's like, and he's in the booth with me and they bring out all their, he's like, you've seen all the art for your character, Horst, the sous chef. And they go, yeah, of course I've seen the art. And this one's my favorite. Look at that. And I'm looking at it going, absorb everything, absorb everything, you know, just, and I'm looking at it.
他，布拉德在那里。他在录音棚里和我在一起，他们拿出了他们所有的，他说，你已经看过你角色霍斯特，副主厨的所有艺术图了。他们说，是的，当然我看过艺术图。这是我最喜欢的。看那个。我看着它，心想，吸收一切，吸收一切，你知道，只是，我看着它。
And then he goes, so obviously, and as you know, cause Horst is German and I'm like, yeah, right. Cause he's German. And I'm thinking like, what the fuck? And I'm thinking, I don't think I do a German apart from like what you do in a bar to a friend. I don't know. And he goes, and then he's like, okay, let's go.
然后他说，所以很明显，正如你知道的，因为霍斯特是德国人，我说，是的，对。因为他是德国人。我在想，什么鬼？我在想，我不认为我会说德语，除了你在酒吧里对朋友说的那种。我不知道。然后他说，然后他说，好吧，开始吧。
And I'm like, what the fuck am I going to do? Same thing. The panic, the sweat, the fucking, and he's right there. And Brad Bird, I revere the guy who made the Incredibles. He's a great director. He's got a super sweet guy. And I just did it. I just bullshitted my way through.
我说，我他妈该怎么办？同样的事情。恐慌，汗水，该死的，他就在那里。布拉德·伯德，我崇拜那个制作了《超人总动员》的人。他是个伟大的导演。他是个超级甜的人。我只是做了。我只是胡扯着完成了。
I did this fucking, the movie exists to this day. Oh my God. Do it. Do it. Three, two, one. German accent. Three, two, one. I did that.
我做了这个该死的，这部电影至今还存在。天哪。做吧。做吧。三，二，一。德国口音。三，二，一。我做了。
That's very good. Four, three, two, one. Now you and Jiminy Cricket. Was he, is he Scottish? Yeah. Sort of very like my. Cause I didn't really know what else to do. So I, he's very close to me.
那非常好。四，三，二，一。现在你和吉米尼蟋蟀。他是，他是苏格兰人吗？是的。有点像我的。因为我真的不知道还能做什么。所以，他和我非常亲近。
Did you go higher? Did you go higher at all? He's just small. He's tiny. So I like, He's weed. I've always shouting everything because, because everyone's so far away. You know,
你提高了吗？你提高了吗？他只是很小。他很微小。所以我喜欢，他很虚弱。我总是对一切大喊大叫，因为，因为每个人都离得那么远。你知道，
It's a very shoooty performance. It's a very shouty performance. But now, Keoh! This summer, in his shoutiest performance to date, Ewan McGregor is... Ewan, I want to hear a little bit of an American accent. Just for a second, just a little bit. I am Jason Bateman.
这是一个非常大喊大叫的表演。这是一个非常大喊大叫的表演。但是现在，基奥！今年夏天，在迄今为止他最大喊大叫的表演中，伊万·麦克格雷格是……伊万，我想听一点美国口音。就一会儿，就一点点。我是杰森·贝特曼。
Yeah. Hey, I'm Jason Bateman. Yeah, that's pretty good. There's so many American accents under. Too manly. It's unbelievable, too manly. Yeah, that was true. Are you excited about something next?
是的。嘿，我是杰森·贝特曼。是的，那相当不错。下面有太多的美国口音。太男人了。简直不可思议，太男人了。是的，那是真的。你对接下来要做的事情感到兴奋吗？
Because you always just pick the coolest stuff, you always work the greatest people. As you like working that much? I tell you what, I've really learned that I like not working, too. Now that we had the experience of being off for that year, you know, with lockdown, and I've never really been that great at not working. I like working and I enjoy it so much, what we do,
因为你总是选择最酷的东西，你总是和最伟大的人一起工作。你喜欢工作那么多吗？我告诉你，我真的学到了我也喜欢不工作。现在我们有了那一年休息的经历，你知道，封锁期间，我从来没有真正擅长不工作。我喜欢工作，我非常享受我们所做的事情，
but I realized that I was actually much better at not working than I thought I was. So now I've got this little boy and I'm with Mary, and I feel like I just want to, I do want to spend less time away and more time at home. So this year I've done very little, I've done a lot of promotion for the Star Wars show this year, and I don't know exactly what I was supposed to be making.
但我意识到我实际上比我想象的更擅长不工作。所以现在我有了这个小男孩，我和玛丽在一起，我觉得我只是想，我确实想减少离开的时间，多花时间在家里。所以今年我做得很少，今年我为《星球大战》剧集做了很多宣传，我不知道我到底应该制作什么。
I had the experience that hasn't happened to me a lot where I was going to be making a movie in Scotland. And so I sort of planned my year about making this movie in Scotland for the whole of the autumn, and it totally just disappeared. I was just texting the director one day about a question about something else, and he went, oh no, we're not doing it.
我有过那种我不太常有的经历，我本来要在苏格兰拍一部电影。所以我计划了我在苏格兰拍这部电影的整个秋天，它完全消失了。有一天我正在给导演发短信问关于别的事情的问题，他说，哦不，我们不拍了。
I was like, oh. Thanks for letting me know. What about Moulin Rouge? Because you were so great in that, would you ever do another musical? Yes, totally. I loved it. And I did a musical on stage after that.
我当时就想，哦，谢谢你告诉我。那《红磨坊》呢？因为你在那部戏里表现得太棒了，你还会再演音乐剧吗？会，当然会。我很喜欢。在那之后我还演过一部舞台音乐剧。
I did Guys and Dolls in London for six months. Oh, that's right. That's right. And I really liked it. It was what an amazing thing to do. It's quite something to get on stage and do something like that every night. A Burroughs, right?
我在伦敦演了六个月的《红男绿女》。哦，没错，没错。我真的很喜欢。那是一次很棒的经历。每天晚上登台表演那种剧目真的很不简单。是伯勒斯（Burroughs）写的，对吧？
A Burroughs? Did A Burroughs write that? Yeah, A Burroughs wrote that. The guy Jimmy Burroughs we were just talking about was on the show. He's our friend. He's a great television director, one of the greatest. And his dad, A Burroughs, wrote it.
伯勒斯？是伯勒斯写的吗？对，是伯勒斯写的。我们刚才提到的吉米·伯勒斯（Jimmy Burroughs）也上过我们的节目。他是我们的朋友。他是一位伟大的电视导演，最伟大的导演之一。而他的父亲，A·伯勒斯，写了那部剧。
Oh, wow. So when you're not being a great dad and a great husband, to fill your days, what would you do? Aside from being a dad and a husband, do you have any dumbass hobby like me and Will playing golf? I do. I have always loved motorbikes and old car and VWs, like old Beetles and buses and stuff.
哦，哇。那么当你不是在做一个好爸爸和好丈夫的时候，你会做些什么来打发时间呢？除了当爸爸和丈夫，你有什么像我和威尔打高尔夫球那样的笨蛋爱好吗？有的。我一直很喜欢摩托车、老式汽车和大众汽车，比如老款甲壳虫、巴士之类的。
So I'm a bit of a... You're out there fixing them up and stuff? Yeah. I like to put potter. I'm not great. I'm not like a mechanic or anything, but I do faff around. I like faffing around in there.
所以我有点……你是在外面修理它们之类的吗？对。我喜欢瞎捣鼓。我不太擅长。我不是什么机械师，但我确实喜欢瞎折腾。我喜欢在里面瞎折腾。
And I spend hours in my shed. Now, what is the goal when you... When I see people working on engines and stuff, it's not just about the difference between making them run and not run. Isn't there like fine tune, like you can make it run a little bit quieter or make it run a little faster?
我会在我的车库里待上几个小时。那么，当你……当我看到人们修理引擎之类的东西时，这不仅仅是让它能跑和不能跑的区别。难道没有那种微调吗？比如你可以让它跑得安静一点，或者跑得快一点？
Like what are you out there? What do you do when you're faffing? He's generally just trying to make them move. So it is about on or off? With the kind of stuff that I like. It's not that fine tuning really. The VWs are pretty simple and I just love them. I love them so much.
你到底在外面做什么？当你瞎折腾的时候你在做什么？他通常只是想让它们动起来。所以这只是关于开或关吗？对于我喜欢的那种东西来说，确实不是那种微调。大众汽车非常简单，我只是喜欢它们。我太喜欢它们了。
How many you got? I have three Beetles and I've got two buses. I've got an old 1960 Rolls-Royce that I love. Did you see the new VW electric car? Yeah. It's pretty cool, huh? I'm actually doing... I'm working with VW now when they promote the new electric bus.
你有多少辆？我有三辆甲壳虫，还有两辆巴士。我还有一辆我非常喜欢的1960年的老式劳斯莱斯。你看到新款大众电动车了吗？看到了。很酷，对吧？我其实正在……我正在和大众合作，推广他们的新款电动巴士。
Because I did that big trip on an electric motorbike and I've been an enthusiast of VWs for years. So we got in touch and we've made a couple of commercials with my old stuff and moving into this new electric bus. Don't they own Porsche now? They always have. Yeah, so many. Porsche and Lamborghini and Ducati.
因为我之前骑电动摩托车进行了一次长途旅行，而且我多年来一直是大众汽车的爱好者。所以我们取得了联系，并用我的旧车和这款新的电动巴士拍了几支广告。他们现在拥有保时捷了吗？他们一直都有。对，有很多。保时捷、兰博基尼和杜卡迪。
VW owns Audi, Audi and Porsche. I drive the new Audi. Who's got a new Audi? Yeah, I drive the new Audi all-electric vehicle. It is my favorite car of all time. It's less written, Sean. Still roaming less written and... No, it really is my favorite car of all time.
大众拥有奥迪、奥迪和保时捷。我开的是新款奥迪。谁有新款奥迪？对，我开的是新款奥迪全电动汽车。它是我有史以来最喜欢的车。它写得更少，肖恩。还在漫游，写得更少，而且……不，它真的是我最喜欢的车。
You and what's the ad that you do for the travel company? I love... Hang on, I just have to say... Expedia. A voiceover guy. I love your intonation on... It's not about the things we have. It's about the...
你和……你为那家旅游公司拍的广告是什么？我喜欢……等等，我必须说……Expedia。配音员。我喜欢你对……的语调。重要的不是我们拥有的东西。重要的是……
What is it? What's the final line? It's the places we go. Well, are we going to live our lives and regret the things that we didn't buy or the places we didn't go? Or the places we didn't go. And the way you say it... Oh.
是什么？最后一句是什么？是我们要去的地方。那么，我们要过完一生，然后后悔我们没买的东西，还是后悔我们没去过的地方？还是我们没去过的地方。你说话的方式……哦。
I fucking love it, man. It's so good, right? Oh, man. They play it on sports all the time. It's so good. I like that. None of my Hyundai reads... No, Jason, I don't...
我他妈太喜欢了，伙计。太棒了，对吧？天哪。他们在体育节目里一直播放它。太棒了。我喜欢那个。我的现代汽车读起来……不，杰森，我不……
Hyundai, you know, it's your journey. You don't like the way I say it's your journey, you know, the way it really hit your, no? You and... When you're on the Expedia, it's so good. Have you heard my lemons? Have you heard my lemons? Yes, lemons.
现代汽车，你知道，这是你的旅程。你不喜欢我说“这是你的旅程”的方式，你知道，那种真正触动你的方式，不是吗？你和……当你在Expedia广告里的时候，太棒了。你听过我的柠檬吗？你听过我的柠檬吗？是的，柠檬。
Lemons. I like the lemons. Lemons. Lemons. Lemons. Yes, you come in on that lemon. I haven't heard that. Lemons.
柠檬。我喜欢柠檬。柠檬。柠檬。柠檬。是的，你用那个柠檬切入。我没听过那个。柠檬。
Lemons. It's very difficult. Is it wrong that I really... I think there was a time back in the train spotting days where I would have been like, fuck that, not doing a fucking advert. And now I'm like, can I do another Expedia? Can we get in touch with Expedia? Nashing his teeth about doing Star Wars.
柠檬。这很难。我真的……是不是有什么不对劲？我想在《猜火车》那个时期，我会说，去他的，我才不拍什么该死的广告。但现在我会想，我能再拍一个Expedia广告吗？我们能联系上Expedia吗？他当时还在为拍《星球大战》而咬牙切齿。
And now it's just like, we're going through all the... Yeah. Well, this is the best, right? Time's changed. Bring it on. I'm like... It's the absolute best. I love doing it too.
而现在就像是，我们正在经历所有的……对。好吧，这是最好的，对吧？时代变了。来吧。我喜欢……这绝对是最好的。我也很喜欢拍它。
It's so good. And we're available. We're available for limes. So, you and... God, we could talk to you forever. It's so great having you here on the show. I really enjoyed it. That was a very fast hour. Yeah.
太棒了。而且我们有空。我们有空拍青柠广告。所以，你和……天哪，我们可以和你聊上一辈子。你能来我们的节目真是太好了。我真的很享受。这一个小时过得太快了。对。
Very fast. God, you're a delight. I didn't have been so nervous. I was very nervous before. I don't know why. No, no, no. I guess because I haven't met you all and I was impressed to be on your show. But I've had a great time.
太快了。天哪，你真是个讨人喜欢的人。我本来不该那么紧张的。我之前非常紧张。我不知道为什么。不，不，不。我想是因为我还没见过你们所有人，而且能上你们的节目让我印象深刻。但我玩得很开心。
I'd love to meet you in person one day. That would be great, buddy. Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to look for something where we've got... We've got a brother thing going. I think we should definitely do that. I'd love that.
我希望有一天能亲自见到你。那太棒了，伙计。对。对。我要找点什么……我们有一种兄弟情谊。我觉得我们一定要做点什么。我很乐意。
We're going to find something. I'd watch the hell out of that. Let's do it. We'd watch the hell out of it. All right, guys. You and such a pleasure. I love you. I'm such a huge fan.
我们会找到点什么的。我一定会看那个节目的。我们来做吧。我们一定会看那个节目的。好了，伙计们。你真是太讨人喜欢了。我爱你。我是你的超级粉丝。
Thank you for being here. Thank you so much. Well, thanks for having me on. Thanks for doing our show, buddy. Thanks for doing it. Great to meet you. Cheers, guys. All right.
谢谢你能来。非常感谢。好吧，谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你来我们的节目，伙计。谢谢你来。很高兴见到你。干杯，伙计们。好的。
Take care. Bye, Yun. See you. Bye. Bye. Wow. We have had nice people on the show. Yeah.
保重。再见，尤恩。再见。再见。哇。我们节目请过不少好人。对。
But really nice people. I feel like he may... That might be the gold right there. As far as just nice, sort of like... Real. There are... I knew, Sean, I've been sitting on this one for a while. And I knew I was like, oh, Sean is going to flip.
但真的是很好的人。我觉得他可能……那可能是最棒的嘉宾了。就那种好，那种……真实。有……我知道，肖恩，我一直憋着没说。我知道我当时想，哦，肖恩肯定会疯掉的。
Just because he played Obi-Wan Kenobi? No, but then in those movies, but then he just came out with a series of Obi-Wan Kenobi. And also just like, I've seen like train spottings in my all time favorite movies. Like that's one of the movies that made me want to be an actor. Really? Yeah. Wow. I just have just been...
就因为他演了欧比旺·克诺比？不，不仅仅是在那些电影里，而且他刚出了一部欧比旺·克诺比的剧集。而且就像，我看过《猜火车》，那是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。那是让我想要成为演员的电影之一。真的吗？对。哇。我只是……
I just always assumed that that's a really good dude. Yeah. And there it is, sure enough. There you go. Yeah. I had heard a couple of people just sort of anecdotally say that he's just the coolest, nicest, realest person. Yeah, I love him.
我一直以为他是个很好的人。对。果然如此，没错。就是这样。对。我确实听过几个人随口说过，他就是最酷、最好、最真实的人。对，我爱死他了。
I know. You know, it's so great. I love his accent is so great. And he's Scottish. And we were talking about the open, which was played in... Up in St. Andrews in Scotland. Not to be confused with the Canadian. There is another St. Andrews, but that's called St. Andrews.
我知道。你知道，这太棒了。我喜欢他的口音，太棒了。他是苏格兰人。我们刚才在谈论英国公开赛，是在……苏格兰的圣安德鲁斯举行的。不要和加拿大的那个混淆了。还有另一个圣安德鲁斯，但那个叫圣安德鲁斯。
Bye. The sea. Bye. The sea. Really well worked in there, Will. That was good. I've been sitting on that since we talked about... No, it just occurred to me and I was like, wow, how am I going to get there?
再见。海边。再见。海边。威尔，你这梗用得真好。那很棒。自从我们谈到……我就一直憋着这个梗。不，我只是突然想到了，我就想，哇，我该怎么引出这个话题呢？
Anyway, bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart.
总之，再见。再见。再见。聪明。最后。聪明。最后。聪明。
Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
最后。聪明。最后。聪明。聪明。更少。聪明。更少。
Less. Smart. Less. This is where we'll start. Smart. Less. This is where we'll start. This is where we'll start.
更少。聪明。更少。这就是我们要开始的地方。聪明。更少。这就是我们要开始的地方。这就是我们要开始的地方。
This is where we'll start. We'll start. Smart. Less. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们要开始的地方。我们要开始。聪明。更少。聪明。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。